THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING-
WILL COME TO ORDER- WE'RE GONNA
START OF SUB COMMITTEE- CENTER
RUBIO IT'S JUST YOU AND ME FOR
NOW- VICE CHAIR SENATOR BATES
THAT YOU'RE RIGHT OUTSIDE-
SHOULD BE BACK IN IN A MINUTE
AND WILL ESTABLISH A QUORUM AS
SOON AS WE HAVE. ANOTHER FEW
MEMBERS- HERE- BY GOOD MORNING-
AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE THE
ONGOING CARBON NINETEEN
PANDEMIC- THE SENATE CONTINUES
TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC AND HAS
PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH IN
PERSON. AND TELECONFERENCE
PARTICIPATION FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS ARE FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT BE A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE DIVERTISSEMENT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED
ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT'LL
BE THIS IT ON THE SCREEN AND ALL
ELSE AND NOW. IT IS EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
FOUR ONE ONE ONE FOUR- ALL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO DISRUPTED. MAY BE
RE REMOTE ANSWER OR HAVE THERE
CAN YOU DID OUR WHOLE- COMMITTEE
HEARINGS IN OUR- STREET
BUILDING- I ASK ALL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO BE PRESENT IN
THE ROOM. HUNDREDS OF ESTABLISH
OUR QUORUM- SO ANY STAFF OR
LISTEN WE'RE WATCHING CLIPS ON
YOUR BOSS- ALL RIGHT DOWN TO
ARKANSAS WAS FORMED. I WE HAVE
TWELVE BILLS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY- AND- WE'RE NOW GOING TO
HEAR FROM OUR FOR OFF. SO SAN
RUBIO WELCOME TO THE HOUSE
COMMITTEE. AND YOU MAY PRESENTS
YOUR BILL WHICH IS SB. NINE ONE
FOUR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT SB NINE ONE
FOUR THE HELP ACT OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS THE HOMELESS EQUITY FOR
LEFT BEHIND POPULATIONS AS OUR
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CONTINUE THEIR EFFORTS TO SOLVE
THE HOMELESS CRISIS WE MUST
ENSURE THAT WE ARE INCLUSIVE OF
THE UNIQUE NEEDS AND EXPERIENCES
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS MAY
BE FACING. NATIONALLY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS ONE OF THE LEADING
DROP CHRIS OF HOMELESSNESS FOR
WOMEN IN APPROXIMATELY 57% OF IN
HOUSE WOMEN REPORT TO MYSTIC
VIOLENCE AS AN IN IMMEDIATE
COSTS OF THEIR HOMELESSNESS AND
TWENTY TWENTY. THE HOMELESS
POINT IN TIME COUNT IN LOS
ANGELES FOUND 49% OF UNSHELTERED
WOMEN AND 67% OF UNSHELTERED
TRANS GENDER INDIVIDUALS
REPORTED EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE BUT DESPITE THE STATE
STATISTICS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS. AND SERVICES HAVE
BEEN GROSSLY UNDERFUNDED GIVEN
THE VOLUME OF UNMET NEEDS FOR
THIS POPULATION OF THE ELEVEN
LARGEST CONTINUUM'S OF CARING
CALIFORNIA ONLY ONE ALLOCATES
THE PERCENTAGE OF FUNDING
EQUIVALENT TO THE PERCENTAGE OF
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
THE HELP ACT WILL ENSURE THESE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS ARE
INCLUDED IN THE WORK THAT CITIES
COUNTIES AND CONTINUANCE OF CARE
ARE CURRENTLY DOING TO ADDRESS.
THIS WE SHOVEL GOALS THAT
ADDRESS THE UNIQUE NEEDS AND
EXPERIENCES OF THIS VULNERABLE
POPULATION AT THE STATE LEVEL
THE HELP ACT WILL REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA INTERAGENCY COUNCIL
ON HOMELESSNESS TO DO JUST THAT
TO INCLUDE THE RISK OF SEXUAL
VIOLENCE AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WHEN SETTING GOALS. THE BILL IS
COSPONSORED BY THREE LEADING
ORGANIZATIONS AT THE CENTER OF
THE INTERSECTION BETWEEN
HOMELESSNESS AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S CENTER
RABAL SERVICES AND THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO END
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THIS BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND IT'S SUPPORTED
BY OVER SEVEN. JURISDICTIONS
PROVIDE AND TAKE ELLEN SERVICE
PRO. JOINING ME BY PHONE TODAY
ARE TWO WITNESSES TO SHARE MORE
ABOUT THE HELP ACT AND IT'S
IMPORTANT. AND ITS IMPORTANCE I
HAVE AMY TURK EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S CENTER AND
SEE SAID SHOT A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HOMELESS SERVICE
COALITION ADVOCATE THANK YOU.
OKAY I'M AND THEY'RE BOTH BY
PHONE YES OKAY SO- IS THE
OPERATOR THERE. THE MODERATOR
THERE YET OKAY GREAT SO WE HAVE
AMY TURK INCIDENTS ARE THEY ON
THE LINE. THEY ARE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I WILL SERVE WITH A METER
. GOOD MORNING CARE WIENER AND
SENATORS MY NAME IS DANNY BURKE
AND I AM THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S
CENTER LOCATED IN THE ADDRESS
UNITY OF ROCK AND WHAT. HAS BEEN
A RUBIO AND WE ARE CO SPONSORS
OF THE BILL YOU SENATE BILL NINE
ONE FOUR HOW MANY YEARS OF WORK
UP WITH UNIQUE NEEDS OF
UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
WITHOUT FILTERING OR DEPENDENT.
AND MATTHEW VIOLENCE. SURVIVORS
HAVE. OVER LIKE IN HE MEANS
THREE MODELS IF AND- THE IS
ROOTED IN OUR THIS FROM OUR AND
SEVENTY EIGHT. DAVID DOWN WOMEN
CENTER FOR EVERY OVER FIVE HOURS
SEVEN AND WOMEN IN YOUR GROWTH
RIGHT PARAGRAPH INCLUDING
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AN ACTIVE
CENTER HELP AND FOR WOMEN AND IT
. WORKFORCE ABOUT AND THOSE
PLANS. AND WE ARE OF THE TRAUMA
RECOVERY IN THE EIGHT. AS
SENATOR STEVEN RUBIO CLEAR
UNDERSTAND THAT THE FINAL ONE OF
THE LEADING. HELLO THE FOR WOMEN
AND NAPOLI ONE THIRD OF ALL FROM
WITHIN- ON A WOMEN. FIFTEEN THAT
WE ARE MEETING ON SEVEN DAY AS
AND IT NINE ONE. WHAT APULEIUS I
CAN'T CENTER THE WAY. AND IT IS
CONSERVTIVE. AREN'T IN THE-
THAT ARE HE'S HELPING YOU AND
HOME. AIR ARE ALREADY
UNDERTAKING. ABOUT YOU KNOW
LOCAL. ANALYSIS AND I. PEOPLE
RETURN HOME. WITHIN THE UNIT.
YOU NOT NEW ACT. NOR WE AT IN
NEW POPULOUS OF. UP IT'S NOT
THAT ENSURES GENDER THE PLAN.
AND THAT THE- AND THE VICTIM.
PROVIDE HELP BRING PROVIDE. ARE
INCLUDED. I APPROVING THIS
SUPPORT BY REPLACEMENT WILL A
TOP OF HOW GENDER I LINE. IN ITS
EFFORTS IN HOMELESSNESS FIVE
ISLAND AND SOMETHING WOMEN YOU
WOULD THANK YOU AND IN ORDER TO
THE RIVER FOR HER CAMPAIGN. OF
CELL NIGHT- THOUGH IN A OF AND
IF NINE ONE LIKE THANK YOU YOU
SO MUCH. THEY YOU VERY MUCH
ANNOUNCED IS SHAW. SURE WHY IN
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
HERE MY BOOK. FOR THE NINE
FORTY. MY NAME IS SHAAM I AM A
WOMAN WHO WITH LIKE THIS IT BRO
FROM A WOMEN'S. NEARLY DECADE.
MY TO BECAME MONNING MY TECH
YOUR MY- DAY I POCKET ADVOCATE.
BILL FROM A WOMAN. MY OF HI LET
THE GRAPH WOULD MEAN BE. I'M ONE
WHAT I HAVE A IS THAT THERE
ISN'T INTEREST ALLAH AND BUILT
ON AT THAT RELATE BLACK WOMEN
COOLEY LAUGH HI- FIVE. HI RIGHTS
HI RICK AND LOW PAY UNTREATED IN
A INTO. PROM THIS COGNITIVE
DISSONANCE HI BEEN TO PROTECT
THREE. THE MAN. I THINK
GENERATION BUT COGNOS BI YOUR
DATE THE REQUESTED L. AT THE NOT
FORTY WHAT HAPPENED OUT OF THAT
ELECT WITH MY WHO COULD GO IN
HIGH SCHOOL QUEEN A BILL CLINTON
I YOU GET A AT EIGHT EQUIPMENT
IN. AND LIVING IN DEMOCRATS
COMMUNITIES TO GET EVIDENCE IN
THE OF. I'M MY JOB. KEEP TRACK
OF YOUR BY AND BILL. WOMEN ARE
WALKING MY FATHER WORK AND
REPORT THAT REPORT NO AND THERE%
. I CAN'T AFFORD TO SUSTAIN MY
PART ANY LAW. NOR DID I HAPPEN
OR IN WHO ON. EVERY I WOULD LIKE
OPEN A FIFTY OUT EVERY PLACE I
HAVE TO EIGHT MY LONG WAY. MY
TIME WITH LIMITED AND HAD A- MY
PAPERWORK AT THE WILL EIGHT ME
GET ROLE WOULD BE ONLY IF I OF
THEM THERE. I COULDN'T FIND WE
THE.
COMPLETE WHEN. I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT B. NINE FOURTEEN SO THAT
NO ONE NO ONE HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN WE ALL THREE ARE GOING
BACK TO UNHEALTHY AND IF YOU
THE- ACTUATION WE CAN NOT. TALK
QUALITY AND EMPOWERMENT WELCOME
TO THE NEW TWENTY FOURTH AT THE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM HERE TO
TESTIFY IN FAVOR OF SB NINE
FOURTEEN PLEASE COME FORWARD
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
THE FACT OF YOUR SUPPORT. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SYLVIA SOLELY
XABI HALF OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE MORNING SHARON REPORT WITH
THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND SUPPORT FOR ANYONE
ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM. IN
SUPPORT SAYING THAT WE'LL GET TO
THE PHONE LINES WILL THE
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
SUPPORT TESTIMONY FOR SB NINE
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU THEY IN
GENERAL YOUR SUPPORT SB NINE
FOURTEENTH PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN
DIRECTED BY. WHEN YOU GO TO LINE
NUMBER THREE THE BILL HAS. MORE
EVEN IF THEY'RE AND MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN ROB BONTA HALF OF YUP THE
PROJECT AND- UP ON THAT. WE HAVE
NOT BEEN THEIR POSITION LETTER
YEP WE ARE WORK ABOUT THE NIGHT.
WITH YOU THANK YOU. NEXT A LINE
NUMBER FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY MY MATTER ON BEHALF OF THE
VALUE CALIFORNIA CONFIDENCE WORK
. THANKS TO A LINE NUMBER TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING GONNA GO THAT BOTH THOSE
STATIONS WITH THOSE WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER ON
CONSTRUCTIVE ORDER AT THE NINE
ONE FOUR THANK YOU. NOW THE LINE
NUMBER TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING ONE ON BEHALF OF
THE COMPANY PARTNERS AND THE
ISLAND THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY INVESTMENT NUMBERS ARE
MEANT ONLY FAMILY HOUSING HARBOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
ALEXANDRIA- OUT BOTH THE
PRODUCERS IS DONE- AND APART
FROM ALL OF. THANK. YOU YEAH.
NEXT WILL LINE NUMBER THIRTY
PLEASED AHEAD. ENTER TO THE
WESTERN CENTER ONLINE FEET APART
YOU. MEXICO TO LINE NUMBER
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING- WITHIN FROM RAINBOW
SERVICES IN STOCKPORT. WELL NOT
QUITE A LINE FOR TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS MOLLY
STAND WITH HELP MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. YEAH I'M NOT GONNA
LIE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING ACCURATE FOR THE
COUPLE HOSTAGE CALIFORNIANS
PHOTOGRAPHY NINE ONE FOUR. WELL
NOT QUITE A LINE NUMBER TWENTY
NINE IS GO AHEAD. YEAH EIGHT
PEOPLE FOR THE STATE'S LIKE A
DROP OF. FIFTY NINE FOUR. NUMBER
ONE NUMBER EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS PART
OF THE BILL HELP ON BEHALF HURRY
I HAVE A FAMILY LIFE BUT THIRD
NIGHT OF. THANK YOU AND ONCE
AGAIN LATE IN GENTLEMEN IF YOU
ARE SUPPORT OF SB NINE FOURTEEN
HE'S PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO AT
THIS TIME. GET YOUR SUPPORT SB
NINE FOURTEEN HE'S PRESS ONE
ZERO. AT NIGHT WHEN I HAVE TO
ONE IN Q. OKAY- WE HAVE NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION TO ASKING
I'M FOURTEEN IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND OPPOSITION
TO SB NINE FOURTEEN. SAYING NO
ONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
CAN YOU TO UP ANY OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION AT THE NINE FOURTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN OPPOSITION
FOR SB NINE FOURTEEN THE FIRST
ONE AND. AT THE TIME WE HAVE
BEEN WANTING TO. OKAY WE WILL
BRING HIM BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- ON THE SCREEN I'M
FOURTEEN. OKAY ST NOW WILL WE
DON'T HAVE AN SUFFERS QUORUM SO
YOU CAN DO THAT YET BUT
HOPEFULLY SOON- SO CENTER RUBIO-
YOU MAY CLOSE WE ARE ONE SHORT
OF A QUORUM AND WE WILL- I HAVE
A MOTION AND VOTE- WHENEVER WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM BUT IF YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I WANTED THINGS TO SET
FOR A FOR HER COMMENTS I WOULD
JUST WANT TO REITERATE WHAT SHE
STATED AND THAT IS THAT
EXTENSIVE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
SOMETIMES HAVE TO MAKE A CHOICE
BETWEEN STAYING IN ABUSIVE
RELATIONSHIP WORK THEY'RE
GETTING ASSAULTED EVERY DAY. AND
BECOMING HOMELESS THAT'S NOT A
REAL CHOICE AND SO THIS WILL
HELP. READY TARGET SOME OF THE
NEEDS OF THESE INDIVIDUALS AND-
I WOULD OUT THAT TRANSGENDER
INDIVIDUALS ALSO FACE EVEN MORE
CHALLENGES SO WE NEED TO TACKLE
THE ISSUE AND MEET THEIR UNIQUE
NEEDS. AND EXPERIENCES AT THIS
THESE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND
WITH THAT I ASK RESPECTFULLY FOR
RIFLES THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR AND- WILL PICK THAT
UP AS SOON AS WE HAVE A QUORUM
SO THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING.
TODAY WE DO HAVE ANOTHER OFFICE
SO- SITES BUILT I WILL HAVE
ANOTHER ONE. EVEN ON MY
APOLOGIES I SHOULD'VE LOOKED AT
THE NEXT ITEM ON THE AGENDA
CENTER OF IT- ITEM NUMBER TWO SB. THIRTEEN OH SEVEN- YOU MAY
PRESENT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN. ONCE AGAIN I AM PROUD
TO PRESENT SB THIRTEEN OH SEVEN
A BILL THAT WILL IMPROVE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF MOBILE.
PARK COMPENSATE MOBILE HOME PARK
RESIDENTS THE IDEA FOR THIS BILL
ACTUALLY CAME FROM THE TORY NOT
MOBILE HOME PARK IN MY DISTRICT.
THAT HAD BURNED DOWN AND HOMES
AND LIVES WERE DESTROYED. AND I
HEARD FROM RESIDENTS WHO WERE
DESPERATE FOR HELP. I THAT THEY
HAD SEEN BROKEN FIRE HYDRANTS
AND I WAS COMMON IN OTHER
FACILITIES AND THERE WAS
MULTIPLE HEALTH AND SAFETY
HAZARDS. AND THE SIDE EVERYWHERE
AND THEY HAD NO IDEA WHO THAT
THEY CAN TURN TO BECAUSE THEY
HAD NOT SEEN A CODE ENFORCEMENT.
INSPECTOR COME IN AND THEY WOULD
CALL HEIR JURISDICTION AND THEY
WERE TOLD THAT'S THE CITY. YOU
KNOW THAT WE CANNOT DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT THAT IS NOT. OUR
JURISDICTION SO MEMBERS TODAY WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S A GAPS BETWEEN
INSPECTION VISITS. AND MOBILE
HOME PARKS THAT CAN INCREASE THE
RISK AND VIOLATIONS. BOB AND
COULD CAUSE DEATH OF UNDETECTED
AND UNREPORTED. WHICH COULD HAVE
FATAL CONSEQUENCES IN A HALF AN
AND ONE MOBILE PARK HOME.
EXISTING LAW HERE IN CALIFORNIA
GIVES THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT THE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR MOBILE HOME PARK INSPECTIONS
WHILE THE DEPARTMENT DOES THE
BEST THAT ACCOUNT IT RESOURCES
ARE LIMITED. AND MANY MOBILE
HOME PARKS GO YEARS WITHOUT A
SINGLE INSPECTION. IN TWENTY
TWENTY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR RELEASED A REPORT THAT
FOUND THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAD
ONLY FORTY SEVEN FIELD
INSPECTORS RESPONSIBLE FOR THREE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY.
MOBILE HOME PARKSACROSS THE
STATE THE AUDITOR FOUND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT FAILED TO INSPECT
OVER HALF OF THESE PARKS BETWEEN
TWENTY TEN. AND TWENTY NINETEEN.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE. THANKFULLY
EXISTING LAW DOES CREATE A
PROCESS FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
ASSUME THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
CONDUCTING INSPECTIONS A MOBILE
HOME PARKS. LOCATED IN THEIR
JURISDICTION THE PART I'M IS
THAT MOST LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PROCESS
EXISTS IN FACT THE MOBILE HOME
THAT I TOWARD THAT HAD BURNED
DOWN WAS WITH THE LOCAL COUNCIL
MEMBER. THAT HAVE BEEN ACCOUNTS
MEMBER FOR NINE YEARS AND HAD NO
IDEA THAT THEY CAN TAKE OVER
JURISDICTION. ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT ONLY ONE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAD REQUESTED THIS
INSPECTION. RESPONSIBILITY SINCE
TWENTY SIXTEEN SB THIRTEEN OH
SEVEN WILL HELP EDUCATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ABOUT THE PROCESS
INTO SIMPLE WAYS ONE IT WILL
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT. TO
CLEARLY POST ABOUT THIS PROCESS
ON ITS WEBSITE AND MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES. TO IT WOULD REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT TO SEND AN ANNUAL
NOTICE TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
EXPLAINING THE PURPOSES. THE
REASON THIS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AS AS AS A FORMAL
LOCAL COUNCIL MEMBER MYSELF I
KNOW THAT WE HAVE HIGH TURNOVER
AND- INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE. IS
GONE AND SO BY SENDING THIS
NOTICE IT WOULD JUST HELP KEEP
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. ARE
INFORMED AND REMIND THEM THAT
THEY COULD TAKE OVER THIS
RESPONSIBILITY. THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY THE GOLDEN STATE
MANUFACTURED HOME OWNERS SLEEK
AND BY SEVERAL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAS NO OPPOSITION. AND BECAUSE
OF SCHEDULE CONFLICTS ARE
WITNESS COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY
THEY'RE UNAVAILABLE BUT THERE IS
THERE IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. BY MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR-
OKAY WE HAVE NO- REGISTERED LEAD
SUPPORT FOR OPPOSITION- SO ALL I
ASK IS THERE IS ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO IS HERE TO
TESTIFY IN FAVOR OF SB THIRTEEN
OH SEVEN. SEEING NONE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES TO PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANY SUPPORT PRESS BE THIRTEEN
OH SEVEN. THANK YOU I LAY IN
GENERAL IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIFTEEN OH SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE BUTTON ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN THAT HARPER SB
THIRTEEN OF THEM IT'S PAST ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND AGAIN
LATE GENERAL IF YOUR SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTEEN OH SEVEN THE BEST
ONE IN ZERO. CURRENTLY WE HAVE
NO PARTY THANK YOU OKAY ARE WILL
NOW GO TO OPPOSITION IS OR
ANYONE IN THE ROOM OPPOSED TO SP
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN. THING NONE
CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION SB
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE ZERO IN OPPOSITION TO
SB THIRTY YOU KNOW THAT. AND
CURRENTLY WE HAVE BILL PARTY
THINK YOU OKAY WILL BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OKAY
SEEING NONE- SENATOR YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU JUST WANTED TO
IT TO READ IT REITERATE THAT THE
FAILURE TO IDENTIFY HEALTH AND
SAFETY VIOLATIONS IN THESE
MOBILE HOME PARKS IN A TIMELY
MANNER MAY REALLY BE
DETRIMENTAL- AND FRESNO THERE IS
A FIRE WHERE SOMEONE LOST THEIR
LICENSE SO WE'RE JUST TRYING TO
SAVE LIVES AND KEEP EVERYONE
HEALTHY WHAT THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR- IVEL THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU WHEN WE ESTABLISH FORM
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION THANK
YOU- I WILL PRESENT I'VE TWO
BILLS TO PRESERVE. SINCE WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH. I WILL.
PRESENT MY BILLS. UNLESS THE
VICE CHAIR.
A. SB NINE THIRTY AND THE
OMNIBUS BILL. YEAH YES PLEASE
BEGIN OKAY I'LL START WITH SB.
NINE THIRTY TO NINE THIRTY-
COLLEAGUES SIDE SB NINE THIRTY
WILL EXPAND THE PROTECTIONS LAID
OUT IN THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT- TO PROJECTS
FOR EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS THOSE MAKING THIRTY
PERCENT- LOTS OF AREA INCOME.
THE THIS INCOME CATEGORY IS IN
DESPERATE NEED OF ADDITIONAL
HOUSING OUR PARTICULAR FOR
HOMELESS POPULATIONS OF THOSE
MOST AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS-
WITH 74% OF HIS HOUSEHOLD
SPENDING MORE THAN HALF OF THEIR
INCOME ON UP ON- HOME- SPENDING
HSA TO COVER EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME PROJECTS IT'S COMMON
SENSE A LONG OVERDUE IT'S A
CURRENTLY COVERS LOW. AND VERY
LOW INCOME BUT NOT EXTREMELY
LOW- SO IRESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. DO YOU HAVE A
PRINCIPAL WITNESS NO NOTHING AND
- SO- ARE THERE ANY- INDIVIDUALS
HERE IN THE CHAMBER THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
S. B. EIGHT NINE OR NINE THIRTY
. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS ANYA
LAWLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION THE PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW PROJECT AND WESTERN
CINEMA POVERTY ON SUPPORT. ANY
OTHER INDIVIDUALS HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IN THIS ROOM.
THEN IT WE WILL MOVE TO OUR
WITNESSES THAT MAY BE WAITING TO
TESTIFY THE OF THE
TELECONFERENCE OR BOTH. MISTER
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE CUTE
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF SB NINE
THIRTY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT SB NINE THIRTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE BEEN THERE WHAT THE
THOUGHT. ONE AND IF YOUR SUPPORT
OF FIFTY NINE THIRTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE START.
CURRENTLY I HAVE A ONE IN Q.
THEN WE WILL MOVE TO THE
WITNESSES THAT MAY BE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM IN THE WITNESS FROM
THIS ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB NINE
THIRTY. SEEING NONE OF THEM ARE
WE WILL GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE MISTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE THIRTY.
THANK YOU REYES DON'T YOU TO
PUSH THE TESTIFIED OPPOSITION TO
SB NINE THIRTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND JAIL AT THIS TIME. BUT IT
APPEARED OPPOSITION SB NINE
THIRTY. ONE POINT ZERO AT THE
START. CURRENTLY HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. THANK YOU THEN WILL RETURN TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THEN WE
DON'T HAVE ANY YOU MAY CLOSE.
THE DESTRUCTION LEFT FOR AN AYE
VOTES- WHENEVER WE ASSEMBLY GET
QUORUM. THEN YOU WANT TO MOVE TO
SB TWELVE FIFTY TWO YES THANK
YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR- COLLEAGUES
S. B. TOP FIFTY TWO IS THE
HOUSING OMNIBUS BILL WHICH MAKES
CLARIFYING NON CONTROVERSIAL NON
POLICY CHANGES TO VARIOUS
COMMITTEE RELATED STATUTES THE
BILL HAS THREE PROVISIONS EACH
PROVISION HAS BEEN REVIEWED AND
APPROVED FOR INCLUSION IN THE
WELL I RELEVANT MAJORITY
MINORITY CAUCUS CONSULTANTS IN
BOTH HOUSES AS WELL AS RELEVANT
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND IN THE
COMMUNITY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IPO. AND I DON'T SEE ANY
PRINCIPAL WITNESS IN SUPPORT
LISTED. THAT'S CORRECT CAN'T.
ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO COME FORWARD- HERE IN THE
ROOM TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. TWELVE FIFTY TWO. SEEING NONE
OUT WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES AND ASK OUR MODERATOR IF
ANYONE IS QUEUED UP TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE FIFTY
TWO. THANK YOU HM WITH YOUR
SUPPORT SB TWELVE IF YOU TO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN AT ONE
ZERO YOUR SUPPORT OF A SPEAK OF
IT. CURRENTLY I HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR THEN
WILL RETURN TO THE ROOM AND SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN THE
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWELVE FIFTY
TWO. SEEING NO WHEN APPROACHING
THE MICROPHONE LET'S GO BACK TO
THE TELEPHONE CONFERENCE LINE
MISTER MODERATOR ANYONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION THAT
MAY HAVE BE BE QUEUED UP. ALL ON
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE. THANK
YOU AND IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
AS DEFAULT IF YOU COULD PLEASE
PRESS ONE DIDN'T DO IT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN AT ONE ZERO ZERO
OPPOSITION SB. TWELVE FIFTY TWO.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
THANK YOU THEN WILL RETURN TO
THE DIE OFTEN ALL IN THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WISH TO SPEAK
TO. SB TWELVE FIFTY TWO THEN YOU
MAY CLOSE WELLS FARGO. WHEN WE
HAVE CORN. THIS IS. WE WANTED WE
ARE OFFERING ALL BILLS. WE'RE IN
A- WHERE THE WHERE THE WHERE THE
PLACID COMMITTEE TODAY THE
ACTION OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
TO PAY MORE FOR IT- OKAY- FOR
SPEED SOMETIMES PERSON'S FAULT-
OKAY I THINK I. AM GOING TO ONCE
AGAIN PUT A CALL OUT TO ANY-
STAFF OF MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE IF YOU COULD PLEASE.
ASK YOUR MEMBER- TO COME DOWN SO
WE CAN ESTABLISH A- WORK THERE
HAD A DAUGHTER PRESENT IF YOU
COULD ASK HIM TO COME DOWN- I
THINK WE WILL NEXT GO CENTER
BATES YOU HAVE A BILL. ITEM TEN
SB TWELVE EIGHTY- YOU MAY
PRESENTS. I'M SORRY- BECAUSE WE
ARE YOU DON'T HAVE TO PRESENT
NOW I JUST- SIR WHAT IS YOUR
MICROPHONE OFF.
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
ARE WERE JUST SORT OF HANGING
OUT FOR A WHILE AND- THERE ARE
NUMEROUS COMMITTEES HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW AND SO WE SHOULD HAVE.
ANOTHER AUTHOR- SHORTLY- SO I
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S PATIENCE.
I'M GONNA GO INTO A FIVE MINUTE
RECESS.
THEIR MEETING OKAY WERE-
RETURNING FROM RECESS- WE ARE WE
HAVEN'T AUTHOR SO WELCOME CENTER
PORTANTINO- YOUR YOUR ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB TEN SIXTY SEVEN
AND- YOU MAY PRESENT. THANK YOU
AYE MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
APOLOGIZE FOR KEEPING YOU
WAITING BUT WAS GRINNING IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE. I'D LIKE TO
START BY ACCEPTING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS LOCATED IN COMMON
EIGHT OF THE ANALYSIS AND THANK
THE CHAIR AND STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK WITH MY STAFF AS WELL- WE
CONTINUE TAKE INPUT ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. AND APPRECIATE
THE WORK SO FAR- PARKING
MINIMUMS REQUIRE PRIVATE
PROPERTY OWNERS TO PROVIDE
MAINTAIN CERTAIN NUMBER OF OFF
STREET PARKING HE'S MINIMUMS
IMPOSE FINANCIAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SOCIAL OSTS
TO CITIES. SB TEN SIXTY SEVEN
WILL PROHIBIT A CITY FROM
IMPOSING MINIMUM PARKING
REQUIREMENT IN HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT THAT IS LOCATED THEN
A HALF MILE BUT TRANSIT AS LONG
AS THERE ARE CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE MET.
INCLUDING A PERCENTAGE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STUDENT
HOUSING A WORK FORCE HOUSING-
AND DISABLED HOUSING AS WELL- SO
WE'RE TRYING TO. HIT THE SWEET
SPOT. OBVIOUSLY AFFECT OUR
DEPENDENCE ON CARS PROVIDE MORE
SPACE FOR WALKING AND BIKING
AND- HELP CREATE MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND SO. THAT'S OUR GOAL
AND APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
CHAIR AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF A CENTER PRINTED ON THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH US IN THOSE
MOMENTS- OKAY. WE DON'T HAVE
ANY- REGISTERED LEAD SUPPORT BUT
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
THE HEARING ROOM TO YOUR- PORT
OF S. B. TEN SIXTY SEVEN SAYING
NONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES.
I WITH MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
SUPPORT FOR SB TEN SIXTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU ARE SUPPORT OF S. B. AND
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN AT THE PORT OF SB ONE ZERO
SIX SEVEN THESE PRESS WANT TO DO
IT. CURRENTLY WE HAVE BOTH
PARTIES CAN QUEUE. OKAY ONE OF
THEIR OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM HERE AND
OPPOSED TO SB TEN SIXTY SEVEN.
SEEING NONE WILL NOT GO TO THE
PHONE LINES CAN YOU PLEASE TO UP
OPPOSITION TO THE SP TEN SIXTY
SEVEN. AND THEN LATER WITH YOUR
IN OPPOSITION SB SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND. AND THAT'S
ONE ZERO ZERO OPPOSITION SB AT
SIXTY SEVEN. AT THIS TIME
EMBODYING YOU BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES OTHER ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THIS
BILL CENTER BATES AND REMEMBER
ANYTHING. OKAY SENATOR
APPOINTMENT CLOSE THANK YOU FOR
YOURCONSIDERATION IN THE HARD
WORK YOU PUT INTO THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO ADDRESS OUR HOUSING
CRISIS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU- AS SOON AS
WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION IN YOUR BILL
ONLY APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION BUT I CENTER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO BACK INTO A
VERY SHORT RECESS.
HEY WE ARE RETURNING FROM A
RECESS- CENTER BACKER WELCOME
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB TEN NINETY
FOUR- YOU MAY PRESENTS. I THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ARE
PLEASED TO PRESENT S. B. AT TEN
NINETY FOUR TODAY THE BILL RUSSO
UNINTENDED BARRIERS AND
DISADVANTAGES TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. AND ALSO
CLARIFY THE CERTAIN TYPES OF
HOUSING CAN BE REPORT FOR CREDIT
UNDER RINA. I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE MEMBERS OUTLINING NOW SYSTEM
I THINK THE CHAIR AND STAFF FOR
WORKING. WITH ME ON THIS BILL.
ROSSER THINKCENTRE ALLEN FIRST
PARTNERSHIP HAS EMERGED ARE TWO
BILLS INTO ONE. THIS BILL
ELIMINATES A REALLY
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE PENALTY THAT
COULD HIT. FOR THE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS IN PLACES THAT HAVE
NOT COMPLIED WITH STATE HOUSING
LAW. RELATED TO HAVING A
ADEQUATE HOUSING ELEMENT. THERE
LOT OF PENALTIES ON BOOKS RIGHT
NOW FOR THOSE CITIES AND
COUNTIES WOULD NOT COMPLAIN
HOUSING ELEMENTS. THEY SHOULD
ABSOLUTELY BE ON THE HOOK FOR
COMPLIANCE RATE OF AN EFFORT A
HOUSING DEVELOPER IN THE CITY
WITH THE REJECTED HOUSING
ELEMENT. PROCEEDS STATE FUNDING.
FOR TWO SPECIFIC FUNDING POTS
AND THEY WILL GET DISQUALIFIED
DO THE CITY'S NONCOMPLIANCE.
THIS IS TOTALLY ACCURATE. IT
PENALIZES WRONG ACTOR. SB TEN
NINETY FOUR MEXICO THE FOR THE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS CAN'T BE
BARRED. FROM RECEIVING FUNDS
FROM THOSE TWO GRANT PROGRAMS
NEARLY THE INFILL INFECTION
GRANT PROGRAM AND THE FORMER
HOUSING SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM. ASCENSION NUMBER CITIES
ARE CURRENTLY OUT OF COMPLIANCE
WITH HOUSING A LOSS THIS IS
RESPONSIVE TO AN ISSUE
HAPPENING. IN REAL TIME. FOR THE
MORE SB TEN NINETY FOUR
AUSTRALIA'S UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THE STATE'S NEW PRO
HOUSING DESIGNATION LAWS. WHICH
PROVIDES INCENTIVES TO LOCALS TO
FACILITATE MORE HOUSING
PRODUCTION. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
CALL. BUT THE INCENTIVES GIVE
EXTRA POINTS TO THOSE CITIES
DURING THE LIKE PROCESS. FOR THE
SAME TO GRANT JUST MENTION. MAKE
A SOME OR OF THE GRANTS
AVAILABLE TO FOR HOUSING VOTE AS
WELL. AS RECOMMENDED BY THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
SB TEN NINETY FOUR WILL ADJUST
THE PRO HOUSING LAW TO MAKE
CLEAR THE SENATE BENEFITS APPLY
ONLY TO PROGRAMS WHICH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE THE SOLE
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS. THAT WAY
FOR THE HOUSE OF A HOUSING
DEVELOPERS SHOULD NOT BE
UNFAIRLY DISADVANTAGE WHEN
COMPETING FOR THESE GRANTS. THE
BILL ALSO CLARIFIES CERTAIN
NONTRADITIONAL HOUSING TYPES.
LIKE SINGLE RESIDENT OCCUPANCY-
OR SRO UNITS CAN BE COUNTED IN
THE CITY'S ANNUAL REPORT FOR THE
RENO. AS WELL AS PERMIT UNITS IN
A MOTEL OR HOTEL CONVERSION FOR
INSTANCE THOSE INCLUDED IN A
HOME K<c.cyan> YOUR ROOM KEY PROJECT.</c>
THIS IS IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE
WE SEVEN FIVE. AT ME SAID OF ICE
PRODUCTION PRODUCTION OF THESE
UNITS AND GIVE CREDIT TO CITIES
WHEN THEY'RE DOING THE RIGHT
WORK. LASTLY THE BILL BILLS ARE
WORK DONE. IN SOME WOMEN
GABRIEL'S AB SEVENTY SEVEN FROM
LAST YEAR THANK SPENDING THE
TYPES OF CONVERTED UNITS. THAT
CITY CAN GET CREDIT FOR. IN THE
APR. BY ADDING VERY LOW AND LOW
COMMUNITIES TO THE TYPES OF
INCOME UNITS. THAT CAN UTILIZE
AB SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN PROCESS.
AS LONG AS THEY INCREASE THEIR
ABOVE MODERATE RINA. ON A ONE TO
ONE BASIS. I UNDERSTAND SOME OF
THE OPPONENTS CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONCERNS OF THE AMENDMENTS- I
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION WITH THEM. AT WHILE
WE MOVE FORWARD. WE DID RUN INTO
SOME TIME CONSTRAINTS- AGAIN
WELL. WELL IT'S TO DRESS SOME OF
THEIR CONCERNS. I WOULD ME TODAY
TESTIFY CAL. SUE THAT RELY OF
THE C. OF PACIFICA MIGHT. WHO IS
TO THE NEED FOR AFFORDABLE CAN.
SECULAR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR SO WE WILL- WELCOME- US
TO BATTLE LOS. GOOD TO SEE YOU
THANK YOU IT'S NOT TO BE HERE
TODAY I JUST IN FAVOR OF THIS-
IN PACIFICA WE HAVE A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY UNITS OF. REGULAR
HOUSING THAT WAS JUST PURCHASED
FOR A 100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
WE NOT ONLY LOSE ALL OF OUR
INCOME OUR TAX FROM THAT
PROPERTY WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
COUNT IT TOWARDS OUR RINA- WE
SPECIFICALLY WANTED THIS S.
ENTIRELY AFFORDABLE. AND OF
SORRY THIS COUNCIL ACTION MADE
THEM A 100% AFFORDABLE ALTHOUGH
IN THE FIRST YEAR WE LOSE ONLY A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS BUT BY YOUR
FIFTEEN WE'RE LOSING TWO POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR ON
PROPERTY TAXES. THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF REVENUE
FOR THE CITY OF PACIFICA AND FAR
EXCEEDS OUR HOUSING AND LIVE
FEEDS- WHICH WE ONLY HAVE THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND IN THAT FUND.
UNFORTUNATELY SINCE WE CAN'T
COUNT IT TOWARDS ARENA- WE LOSE
IN TWO WAYS IT REMOVES THE
INCENTIVE FOR PEOPLE TO
PURCHASE. OF BUILDINGS AND TURN
THEM INTO AFFORDABLE HOUSING IF
WE HAVE A LOSE LOSE FOR THE
CITY. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR SB TEN
NINETY FOUR. IN THE HEARING ROOM
SAYING I'M WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MODERATOR KEY PLEASE QUEUE
UP SUPPORT FOR TEN NINETY FOUR.
IF YOUR YARD WORK FOR THE NINETY
FOUR AT ONE HOUR FIVE. WHEN.
EIGHT ZERO. MISTER JERICHO BUT
HE IS DOING UP. I'M OKAY ARE
WILL NOW GO TO ANY OPPOSITION SB
TEN NINETY FOUR- WE HAVE. EXCUSE
ME. ON YOUR LAWLER AND BRIAN
AUGUSTA LAWLER OR TO SIGN LAWLER
. JUST MEOKAY- GOOD GOOD GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BOURZAT
ALERT SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AS WELL AS
FOR MY COLLEAGUES AT THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WE DO
UNFORTUNATELY STILL HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED ON THE
BILL- AND CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE LANGUAGE EVEN
AS IT LEAVES THE COMMITTEE.
HOWEVER MUCH APPRECIATE THE TIME
WE SPENT WITH CENTER BACK OR
TALKING ABOUT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES HE'S TRYING TO
ADDRESS AND HIS COMMUNITIES AND
AROUND THE STATE I'M CERTAINLY
AGREE THAT WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE
CONVERSIONS FOR MARKET RATE TO
IT TO LIVE COME WHERE WE CAN-
AND CERTAINLY AGREE THAT WE WANT
TO INCENTIVIZE CITIES TO DO
WHATEVER THEY CAN TO CREATE A
WIDE RANGE OF HOUSING TYPES TO
SERVE LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
BUT JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE DO
THAT. IN THE MOST PRODUCTIVE WAY
THAT DOESN'T. CUT AGAINST OTHER
REALLY IMPORTANT HOUSING GOALS
SO HAPPY TO HAPPY TO KEEP HAVING
A CONVERSATION AND I'M CONFIDENT
THAT WE CAN WORK IT OUT BY THE
TIME THE BILL GETS THE ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU FOR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BEFORE. WE GO TO ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION. LIGHTNING HAS STRUCK
AND WE HAVE A QUORUM. AND SO
LET'S ESTABLISH- THE CORN BEFORE
WE LOSE. I WAS. SENATOR WIENER
RESIDENT CENTER BATES YEAH
CENTER COURT HASN'T SENATOR
CAFIERO. MCGUIRE PHOTOBOOK ENTER
NUMBER ABSOLUTELY- WHAT KASKY
HERE WE WANT I REQUIREMENTS BEEN
ESTABLISHED THANK YOU OKAY-
WILLIAM IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE ROOM
SAYING NINE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR THE MODERATOR PLEASE
TO UP ANY OPPOSITION TO THE SP
TEN NINETY FOUR. IF YOU ARE IN A
BIT OPPOSITION AT THE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE DESPITE.
ONE ZERO. YOUR OPPOSITION THE L.
B. AND I FOR. YOU KNOW. BOEING
HOUSE ON THE ABOUT THE STRUCTURE
OF THE GOING UP OKAY WILL BRING
BACK TO THE I'LL CALL ANY CLUE
ARE. FEDERER CABALLERO. YEAH I
I'M I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT I'M
IN MY APOLOGIES- I SHOULD JUST
READ THIS A LITTLE BIT MORE
CAREFULLY I THINK- IT IS SENATOR
BAKER- THE OPPOSITION RAISES
SOME GOOD POINTS AND SO WHAT.
WHAT IS WHAT'S YOUR POSITION ON
ON- ON ON THE ISSUES THAT THEY
RAISED AND WHETHER YOU'RE-
INTERESTED IN TRYING TO. TEN AM
MEETING AT ARAB YEAH WHICH WHICH
PIECES WE ON THE CONVERSE PEACE
IN OR IN THE INTERIM IN THE
CONNECTION FOR YOU CAN ARMS
COMING OUT OF THE BILL OKAY OKAY
YET ROUGHLY AROUND THE JUST TO
BE CLEAR IN THE COMMITTEE MA'AM
AND CINEMA THANKS FOR WITH US.
THE PIECE ABOUT HOME SHARING AN
INTERIM HOUSING ON IS BEING
REMOVED FROM THE BILL OKAY
THAT'S REALLY HELPFUL BECAUSE
THAT'S YEAH YEAH FOR THE MOTELS
AND CALIFORNIA. YES THE THEIR
VARIOUS PIECES REMAINING ONE IS-
IF- YEAH NOT FOR THE THAT AT
CLARIFYING THE SRO. HOUSEBOATS
QUALIFY- WHICH WE THINK IS
PROBABLY CURRENT LAW BUT IT'S
HELPFUL TO CLARIFY IT- IN
ADDITION AND- OUR CONVERSION OF
MARKET RATE- DEED RESTRICTED. LO
LÎNG VERY. LOW INCOME. WHAT I
INCREASE TO THE MORE RATE RENA-
DOT WILL BE THE MOTTO-
CONVERSION PIECE OF THE- AND I
WAS A SAID THE THAT. THAT THE
CENTER WILL CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
WITH THE OPPOSITE- WE DID BUNCH
OF WERE ON THIS I'M SURE- IT
GETS TO ASSEMBLY THAT. ASSEMBLY
HOW I MANAGE. WE'LL HAVE SOME
OPINIONS ON THESE ISSUES AS WELL
BY APPRECIATE THE COLLABORATION
SO I APPRECIATE THAT
CLARIFICATION THANK YOU FOR THAT
MISTER CHAIR I GUESS. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I ALWAYS GET A
LITTLE BIT PARANOID ABOUT IS-
WEALTHY COMMUNITIES DECIDING
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO COME UP
WITH ANOTHER WAY OF BEING ABLE
TO MEET THEIR NUMBERS THAT ARE
REALLY FUNNY BALONEY I MEAN I AM
NOT SAYING YOU'RE DOING THAT.
IT'S JUST- IT'S LIKE WHEN MARIN
COUNTY CAME IN AND ASKED FOR AN
EXEMPTION FROM THE RENO NUMBERS
AND THEY GOT IT IT'S LIKE. THAT
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE TO ME- WE
PART OF THE CHALLENGE THAT WE
HAVE IS THAT WHEN COMMUNITIES
DON'T BUILD THEIR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THEY PUSH THEM OUT TO
OTHER COMMUNITIES AND THAT PUSH
OUT IS CREATING- GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS EMISSIONS BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE DRIVING FURTHER AND
FURTHER AWAY- AND IT'S PUSHING.
THE DISCUSSION ABOUT BIG MILES
TRAVELED AND THE ENTITIES THAT
ARE HAVING TO DO THAT SYSTEM
HAVE THE DIFF THE WITH IT ARE
THERE A RURAL COMMUNITIES. ARE
STRUCTURE IN PLACE- THROUGH
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION AND SO I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT DOING THAT AND I APPRECIATE
THAT CLARIFICATION SOUGHT. YEAH
RESPOND- YEAH I NEED IT UNITS
AND THE WE NEED UNITS ALL LEVEL
AND MY A MY DISTRICT CERTAINLY
AT THE LOW AND VERY LOW- WE
ACTUALLY NEED THOSE UNITS-
ISSUES ARE VERY EXPENSIVE YOU
KNOW IT'S ALMOST SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR SUBSIDY FOR ONE
UNIT OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT WITH THIS
BILL JUST HOW CAN WE
INCENTIVIZE- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
INCLUSIONARY ZONING THAT'S GONNA
GET US PART OF THE WAY THERE
BUT- THAT'S MAYBE 1015% AWAY
THEIR- AND- WE'RE GONNA
HOPEFULLY PAY IT THAT PASSED BIG
BEAR HOUSING- FUND. TO FUND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OTHER CITIES
ARE LOOKING FOR A HUSBAND WE ASK
THAT YOU KNOW AND SENT IT AND
THIS CONVERSION AND THAT LIKE IN
THE CASE OF PACIFICA. THEY DO IT
RIGHT THE FIRST THEY JUST DIDN'T
GET CREDIT FOR IT FOR THE WEB
LAW IS CURRENTLY WORK. BUT THOSE
ARE NOW DEED RESTRICTED
AFFORDABLE UNITS. AND THERE IS A
LOT OF KIND OF NATURALLY
OCCURRING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
OUR MIDST IN OUR DISTRICT. THAT
WERE VERY WORRIED WE'RE GONNA
LOSE. AS YOU KNOW THEM AS THE
MARKET KEEPS GOING UP AND UP
SOMEBODY EVENTUALLY GOING TO BUY
THAT AND YOU KNOW PUT IN. YOUR
GRANT OR TOPS IN AND SALAS THE
CHARGE YOU KNOW TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS MORE. AND SO WE WANT TO
PROTECT THAT AS MUCH AS WE CAN
AND WE THINK WE'VE- WITH THIS
BILL WE WERE STRIKING THAT
BALANCE HOPEFULLY TO PROTECT
THEM. AND MAKE IT AFFORDABLE.
OKAY ANYTHING ELSE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OKAY I THINK I WANT TO
THANK THE CENTER FOR WORKING
WITH US I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
THE WAY WE WE'VE REVISED THE
CONVERSION THAT IF YOU TAKE
MARKET WHAT IS MARKET RATE
HOUSING NOW AND CONVERTED TO
DEED RESTRICTED LOW INCOME VERY
LOW INCOME EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
. ANY OTHER TO GOOD THING
INCREASING THE SUPPLY OF THAT
BELOW MARKET RATE HOUSING- BUT-
IN THE ORIGINAL VERSION OF ONE
OF CANNIBALIZED- IN TERMS OF.
THE RENO FOR- IN TERMS OF MARKET
RATE. HOUSING WHICH- IS ALSO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IF WE'RE NOT
BUILDING MARKET RATE HOUSING-
THEY WERE TELLING THE MIDDLE
CLASS TO SCREW OFF- BECAUSE THE
MIDDLE CLASS IS NOT GOING TO BE
ELIGIBLE. FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSING- AND THE ONLY WAY TO
SOLVE OUR MIDDLE CLASS HOUSING
PROBLEM IS TO. DO IT THE OLD
FASHIONED WAY AN OLD JUST A LOT
OF HOUSING. AND SO THE REVISION
THE AMENDMENT WILL SAY THAT IF
YOU TAKE A FIFTY UNIT COME UP
FIFTY UNIT. MARKET RATE
APARTMENT BUILDING AND MAKE IT.
THE CONVERTIBLE- MARGARITA LOW
INCOME THAT'S GREAT I CAN COUNT
AGAINST YOUR LOW INCOME- RINA
BUT THEN YOUR MARKET RATE RENO
WILL GO UP BY FIFTY UNITS
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO REPLACE A
HOUSING- AND CYPRESS YOU
ACCEPTING THAT AMENDMENT- AND
WITH THAT- AS AMENDED I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL AND YOU MAY
CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT
VOTE THANK YOU FOR COMING. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- OKAY- DO WE HAVE
A MOTION- ON THE MOTION ON I
WORKED OUT WE CAN ACTUALLY TAKE
A MOTION A MOTION ON A SPEECH
TEN NINETY FOUR. MOTION BY
CENTER LIKE HOW SKI- WE WILL.
THE ROLL. THIS IS SENATE BILL
ELEVEN OF TEN NINETY FOUR BY
SENATOR BAKER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER
AYE. WIENER AYE BATES. CABALLERO
FIVE CAREER AYE CORTESE. MCGUIRE
BUT CHAU BOOK SKINNER. I'M BURKE
RIGHT. I'M BURKE AYE FOR CASKEY
HI. WHAT HAS KEEP HI. ON THE FOR
OKAY THAT IS FOR BOTH WILL PUT
ON CALL FOR THE MEMBERS THANK
YOU- AND WHY WE GO HAVE- OTHER
BILLS SO WE'VE HEARD THAT WE
NEED MOTIONS ON- WHAT. I'M SORRY
OKAY I WANTED TO JUST TAKE ALL
THESE OTHER BILLION- THAT'S WHEN
WE LET'S OPEN THE ROLE FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS OSCAR TEN NINETY
FOUR SERVING AS SORT OF SKINNER
ON A BILL. THIS IS TEN NINETY
FOUR THE CURRENT VOTE IS FORTY
ZERO CHAIR VOTING I. ADVISED HER
NOT VOTING. CENTER SKINNER.
CENTER SKINNER HI. OKAY SO THE
TOP FIVE NOTHING ON THE ON SB
TEN NINETY FOUR WILL PUT ON
CALL- CENTER ALLEN JUST ONE
MOMENT WE FINALLY HAVE A QUORUM
SO I WANT TO GET SUGGESTIONS ON
BOTH MY LAN OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA
GO TO ITEM NUMBER ONE SB NINE
FOURTEEN BY CENTER RUBIO DRIVE
IN MOTION ON A SCREEN NINE
FOURTEEN. MOVED BY SENATOR
BATES- AND WE WILL CALL THE ROLL
. THIS IS SENATE BILL NINE
FOURTEEN BY SENATOR RUBIO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER
AYE WIENER AYE BATES. HI
CABALLERO RIGHT CABALLERO I
CORTES HE- MCGUIRE. PATROL BOAT
SKINNER. IN- HI NUMBER FIVE
NUMBER FIVE WITH HOUSEKI RIGHT
CASKEY I VOTED SIX TO ZERO OKAY
WE WILL PUT THAT BILL ON CALL I
KNOW NUMBER TWO S. UNDER BY
CENTER CABALLERO WILL CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS SENATE BILL ONE
THREE ZERO SEVEN BY SENATOR
RUBIO THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WIENER AYE WIENER AYE
BATES ALL RIGHT BATES HI
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I CORTES HE
MCGUIRE MITCHELL BROKE SKINNER
FIVE SKINNER HI NUMBER. NUMBER
CENTER I'M BURKE I. WHAT HAS HE
FIVE. WHAT CASKEY I THE BILL TO
SIXTY ZERO WHAT ABOUT BILL ON
CALL I ITEM NUMBER THREE SB TEN
SIXTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO I DO HAVE A MOTION-
MOVE BY CENTER CABALLERO THAT'S
AS AMENDED. I WILL CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS SENATE BILL TEN
SIXTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER
AYE. WIENER AYE BATES NOPE BATES
NO CABALLERO. EARLIER HI CORTESE
. REQUIRE MITCHELL BROKE SKINNER
RIGHT. SKINNER I NUMBER FIVE
NUMBER I REQUEST FIVE. WITH
HOUSEKI I VOTERS FIVE TO ONE
REPORTER CALL TO HAVE A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH IS
ITEM FOR S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. ITEM SIX SB ELEVEN THIRTY
FOUR AM EST FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
ITEM NINE SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
NINE. HEY MOTION BY SENATOR
SKINNER WILL CALL THE ROLL. ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH WHICH
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS FOR SIX
EIGHT AND NINE SENATOR WIENER
AYE WIENER AYE BATES. BATES HI
CABALLERO CABALLERO HI CORTES
MCGUIRE BUT CHOI BOGUE SKINNER
BY SKINNER HI NUMBER. FIVE
NUMBER FIVE WITH HOUSEKEEPING
FIVE WHAT KASKY BY THE VOTE IS
SIX TO ZERO OKAY WE'LL PUT THAT
OUT WILL PUT ACCOUNT ON CALL ON
THAT I A LOT OF IN. RIGHT
CORRECT AT ELEVEN S. B. NINE
THREE THE MOTION. NINE THIRTY.
MOST OF MY SENATORS PLEASE THE
ROLL THIS IS SENATE BILL NINETY
BY SENATE WIENER THE MOTION IS
TO PASS SENATOR WIENER AYE
WIENER AYE BATES RIGHT THEY HI
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I. MCCOY A
CHOKE SKINNER HI SKINNER HI
NUMBER. NUMBER I WOULD ASK LIGHT
WHAT HAS I SIX ZERO NOW IT'S TO
THE FOR. YES OKAY WE'LL PUT THAT
ON CALL AND FINALLY S. B. I
DON'T EVER TALK S. B. TWO FIFTY
THE HOUSE ON THE BUS STILL.
MOVED BY CENTERS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE SENATE TWELVE TWOBY
THE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON A PER.
SENATOR WIENER HI WIENER AYE
BATES RIGHT BATES HI COMMITTEE
HI CABALLERO HI CORTEZ. REQUIRE
BUT CHAU BOOK SKINNER. RIGHT
SKINNER HI I'M BURKE. I NUMBER
FIVE WHICH- HI MY CASKEY I IS
SIXTY OKAY PUT UP ALONG. CENTER
ALAN WALKER AND IN SEVEN SB
ELEVEN ON FOUR- YOU MAKE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LOOK ME THINK
BY THE MOVEMENT START. THE CHAIR
HI AT YOU'RE VERY COMMITTEE
STAFF- YOUR- OF THIS BILL IN
ALSO PARTNERS. THAT WE'VE- IN IN
TRYING TO DRESS- AND IMPORTANT
THE END OF ISSUE. I SO AT
GENDERS. RESTROOMS HAVE LONG
OPPOSED- SOME CONCERN FOR-
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY- AND
THIS BILL CAME TO ME FROM WEST
HOLLYWOOD WHICH IS A CITY MY
DISTRICT. THAT THE JOURNALS
WELL- THAT IS BEEN THE HEART OF
OUR LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY IN LOS
ANGELES FOR A LONG TIME. AND
CONCERNS CAME UP THROUGH THE
CITY THERE ABOUT HOW GENDER
NONCONFORMING INDIVIDUALS- FOR
THAT GENDER SEGREGATED BATHROOMS
OFTENTIMES CAN BE THE SIDE OF
VERBAL HARASSMENT PHYSICAL
ATTACKS EVEN SEXUAL ASSAULT. ARE
AND THE COURSE FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES AND PERSONAL
CARE GIVERS FOR CHILDREN AND
ADULTS GENDER SEGREGATED
RESTROOMS HOW PLACE MANY. IN THE
UNCOMFORTABLE POSITION OF NOT
USING FACILITIES THAT SORT OF
USING FACILITIES THAT ARE NOT
DESIGNED WITH THEIR NEEDS IN
MIND AND I'LL GIVE YOU A
PERSONAL EXAMPLE I MEAN I'M I'M-
MANY OF YOU KNOW I'VE GOT A
LITTLE. LITTLE GUY THREE YEARS
OLD. AND- WE GET OFF AN AIRPLANE
FOR EXAMPLE AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT THERE'S A
THERE'S A FAMILY BATHROOM THAT'S
AVAILABLE WE GET OFF THE PLANE
SO WE CAN GET IN THERE I
CERTAINLY WHEN- WHEN HE WAS
BREAST FEEDING WEEK GOT USE THE
RESTROOM MAYBE CHANGE A DIAPER
WE GO IN TOGETHER AS A COUPLE.
ARM AND NOT HAVE TO HAVE ONE
PARENT GO AND- AND MAKE THINGS
MORE DIFFICULT FOR THE PARENTS.
SO ANYWAY I THINK WE ALL BELIEVE
THAT RESTAURANTS SHOULD BE SAFE
AND INCLUSIVE TO ALL REGARDLESS
OF AGE HEALTH CONDITION OR
GENDER IDENTITY. OUR THE
CHALLENGE WE RUN INTO AND THIS
IS WHY THE BILL CAME TO US FROM
FROM THE CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD
IS THAT EXISTING STATUTES- LIMIT
THE AUTHORITY OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO EXPLORE
COMMONSENSE METHODS OF EXPANDING
ACCESS AND EFFICIENCY IN THE
SPACE SO THIS BILL GIVES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE ABILITY TO
ORDINANCES OR RESOLUTIONS THAT
REQUIRED. CONSTRUCTED ARE
SIGNIFICANT RENOVATED PLACES OF
PUBLIC ACCOMMODATION TO HAVE
MULTIPLE STYLE PUBLIC RUSSIAN
FACILITIES THAT ARE DESIGNED AND
CONSTRUCTED WITH SINGLE USER
TOILET COMPARTMENTS AND
IDENTIFIED FOR USE BY ALL TYPES
OF FOLKS ARE FROM DIFFERENT
GENDERS. AND SO THIS IS ENTIRELY
PERMISSIVE. THIS THE DECISION
WOULD BE MADE BY THE CITY THE
LOCAL JURISDICTION. ARM OUT AND
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT ONE OF MY
CITIES AS I MENTIONED HAS- HAS
COME TO ME TO TAKE TO GET
RECTIFIED AS THEIR TIES ARE
TRYING TO. WHEN THEIR WAY
THROUGH THE CODE. SO I
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY FROM
THE CITY WEST HOLLYWOOD WE HAVE
THE MAYOR PRO TEM SEPI SHINE AND
THEN ALSO COUNCILMEMBER JOHN
ERICSSON. OKAY THANK YOU- SO
WE'LL HEAR FROM- COUNCILMAN
NUMBER ERIKSEN AND FROM MAYOR-
SHINE. GOOD MORNING ON A CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS SHY AND I AM THE MAYOR
PRO TEM OF THE CITY OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD LAST YEAR AFTER
THE CITY COUNCIL MY COLLEAGUE
COUNCIL MEMBER JOHN ERIC AND
WITH. ALSO LEFT IN NOVEMBER AND
I INTRODUCED A MOTION DIRECTING
STAFF TO IMPLEMENT MULTI STALL
GENDER NEUTRAL RESTROOMS IN WEST
HOLLYWOOD. MUCH TO OUR SURPRISE
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING CODES
WHICH WEST HOLLYWOOD FOLLOWS IS
NOT ALLOW OUR THIRTY THREE
CLARITY ADDING A RESTAURANT. THE
LESBIAN WOMEN OF COLOR WHO HAS
MANY TRANSGENDER AND GENDER
NONCONFORMING FRIENDS I WANTED
TO DO SOMETHING TO ADDRESS THE
FACT THAT SOME OF MY FRIENDS AND
THOUSAND RESIDENTS AND VISITORS
IN CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCE EVERY
TIME THEY USE THE BATHROOM YOU
THINK ABOUT THAT. BILL SIMPLE
FACT OF USING A SHAM WHICH BY
BUT THE NOT IN ITS WITH TO THINK
OF. CAN AND IS A THREAT ON SOME
HARMFUL SITUATIONS
TRANSGENDERISM NON COME PEOPLE I
THINK YOU WILL WITH THAT THAT
THIS NOT BE THE CASE IN PROGRESS
THE FORWARD THINKING INCLUDES
CALIFORNIA. I STATES HAS LED THE
NATION IN MANY ISSUES BREAKING
DOWN BY FILLING THREE RIPPING
OFF AND BRIBING DIVERSITY AND
CREATING OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE
WHO ARE IT IS MANAGED THE CRIED.
VIOLENCE AND TOLERANCE ARE VERY
REAL FACT OF LIFE FOR
TRANSGENDER AND GENDER
NONCONFORMING PEOPLE MAKING
RESTROOMS GENDER NEUTRAL IS THE
RIGHT STEP FOR OUR CITY AND MANY
OTHERS IN THE STATE SB ELEVEN
NINETY FOUR WILL GIVE CITIES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHOOSE TO REQUIRE
MULTI FELL GENDER NEUTRAL
RESTROOMS IN PLACE OF PUBLIC
ACCOMMODATION THAT ARE NEWLY
BUILT WITH THOSE THAT UNDERGO
SUBSTANTIAL. REMODELING ALL OF
YOU HAVE TAKEN BOTH LEADERS AND
A OUR STATE A SHINING. OF
INCLUDES THE AND CAUGHT. I URGE
TO STILL BE THE AND PASS THE
BILL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
CONSIDER. THANK YOU ENACT
WITNESS IN SUPPORT IS- CAL
MEMBER ERIC. GOOD MORNING ALL
OUR BOOK FAIR MEMBERS OF THE CAN
MONEY IS DONNA I'M NOT HOW
MEMBER IN VIDEO WEST HOLLYWOOD I
WAS ELECTED THE COUNCIL AFTER
THREE ON THE LET AGAIN BOARD AND
PLANNING COMMISSION WHERE ALONG
WITH ALL MY COLLEAGUES LIKE
MAYOR PRO TEM SHINE AND I WE
HEARD FROM MANY PEOPLE ABOUT THE
NEED TO MAKE MULTI STALL
RESTROOMS GENDER NEUTRAL. AT THE
CHIEF OF STAFF TO LONGTIME
FORMER MAYOR AND COUNCILMEMBER
ABBE LAND I WAS PART OF THE
ORIGINAL PASSAGE OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD GENDER NEUTRAL
BATHROOM INTERESTING GOLF BALL
RESTAURANT CITY WIDE AND THIS
ISSUE IS NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART THE POLICY MAKER GAME MAKE
GAME MAN AND LEADER. AS THE
MAYOR PRO TEM INDICATED USING
THE RESTROOM CAN BE A STRESSFUL
EXPERIENCE FOR TRANS AND GENDER
NONCONFORMING PEOPLE IT CAN ALSO
BE AWKWARD EXPERIENCE FOR
DISABLED INDIVIDUALS REQUIRED
THE ASSISTANCE OF A CAREGIVER
WHO MAY BE OF THE OPPOSITE
GENDER THERE SHOULD BE NOT
SHOULD THERE SHOULD NOT BE ANY
AWKWARDNESS ABOUT USING THE
RESTAURANT ANYWHERE. CALIFORNIA
HAS LED THE NATION MANY TIMES
BEFORE AND SHOULD LEAD A MULTI
STALL GENDER NEUTRAL RESTROOMS
THROUGH AT ELEVEN NINETY FOUR
IT'S GOOD FOR ALL COMMUNITIES
THAT RECOGNIZE THE THIRD I
PERSONALLY AND PROVIDE THE
STATE'S RATES FOR ALL SB NINE
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR ALSO RESPECT
FOR THE LOCAL CONTROL BY
ALLOWING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
OPT IN INTO THESE NEW
REGULATIONS. BY ADOPTING AN
ORDINANCE FURTHERMORE THE BILL
AFFORD COMMUNITIES THE
DISCRETION TO DEFINE THE LEFT
THE PROJECT THAT WILL BE SUBJECT
TO THE REQUIREMENTS OR EXEMPTED
FROM THEM. SB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR
WILL CODIFY IMPORTANT CHANGES IN
BUILDING CANDOR ABOUT OUR
COMMUNITY MAKE THIRTEENTH RIGHT
THEY FACE IS TRANSGENDER
NONCONFORMING PEOPLE AS WELL AS
PEOPLE LIVING PHYSICAL
DISABILITY ANOTHER PART OF THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT THAT I
WOULD C. Q. PARENTS. UP BOB
AFTER THE FACT GRANDSTANDING THE
AS IN THE NOW THAT THE COMMITTEE
THAT YEAH WELL THE BY TO TALK
WITH BENEFITS SO PROSTITUTION
DIRECT ACTION WHAT REQUIRED IF
YOU CALL A PRESS THE MARKET OF
GENDER NEUTRAL THE BILL. I WANT
TO THANK CENTER. BEN ALLEN.
THAT MIGHT BE HERE IN THIS ROOM
ANYONE WANT TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBER SYLVIA SO LEASE SHAH HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA WE ARE PROUD TO BE CO
SPONSORS OF THE MEASURE AND THIS
IS IN LINE WITH OUR PRIORITY TO
MAKE SANTA MONICA SAFE AND
INCLUSIVE PLACE FOR ALL. THANK
YOU. OKAY THEN I DON'T SEE
ANYONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT SO WE'LL
GO TO THOSE ON THE PHONE LINE TO
MR MODERATOR. WILL YOU QUEUE UP
THOSE WHO ARE WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF SB ELEVEN NINETY
FOUR. EIGHT YOU THEY DIDN'T GET
OF YOUR SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
NINETY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THERE. FIVE ONE. ONE ZERO YOUR
SUPPORT AT ELEVEN NINETY FOUR.
FOR YOUR LINE NUMBER IF HE IS BY
HAS. AT THE SAME MY MOTHER I'M
OF HE VALUE CALIFORNIA ACT THE
COURT. JUST ONE FORM ALL THE
PEOPLE WITH THE TAX PART. WELL
NOW BUT Y. NUMBER THIRTY SIX
BASEBALL HAT. YES THIS IS ERIN
FOX NOT BOX INTO A FAILED TO
BEAT THE THUNDER WE ARE CLOSED
ON- AND IN STRONG WORK THANK YOU. ONE CAN LATEST GEMINI YOU ARE
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR
HE'S BUT ONE THOUSAND ZERO AT
THE SPOT. CURRENTLY WE HAVE BOTH
PARTIES THINK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL THEN WE WILL NOW GO TO
THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN NINETY
FOUR AND I DON'T SEE ANYONE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE HERE
IN THE ROOM SO WE WILL GO TO
THOSE ON THE PHONE MISTER
MODERATOR WOLD YOU QUEUE UP.
ANYONE WHO IS PRESENT ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE THAT WISHES
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU
LADIES DON'T JOIN OPPOSITION S.
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR IS BUT WANTS
TO DO IT THIS TIME. ONE CANNOT
ONE ZERO YOUR OPPOSITION S. B.
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR. AT THE TIME
I HAVE BIPARTISAN Q. THEN WILL
RETURN TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND- SENATOR SKINNER WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE A COMMENT. I THANK YOU
VICE CHAIR- SENATOR I WANTED
PRECIADO YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL BEFORE ST CITY OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD- I. WANT TO MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS THE NUMBER OF THE BILL.
I ALSO WANTED TO PRESHEAF STAFF
IN THE ANALYSIS THEY MADE SOME
OTHER POINTS THAT THE TESTIMONY
SO FAR HAS BEEN SPOT ON ABOUT
THE NEED FOR THIS FOR OUR-
TRANSGENDER FOLKS AND OUR NON
CONFORMING FOLKS HOWEVER. WHAT
WE ALSO KNOW AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ANALYSIS POINTING
IT OUT THAT OUR PRACTICE OF
PRIMARILY HAVING YOU KNOW JUST
AND IN MAN'S BATHROOM OR WOMEN'S
BATHROOM. IS LED TO MOST OF US
WOMEN WHO GO TO ANY KIND OF
PUBLIC EVENT WAIT A LONG TIME
HIS FOR THAT'S TRUE. AND SO WE
YOU KNOW AND- IT IT'S WE'VE
UNDERSTOOD NOW THAT MAKE A LOT
OF SENSE TO IF ONE RESTROOM IS
EMPTY LET'S USE. IT RIGHT AND
THEN YOU ALSO HAVE. YOUR MANY
PEOPLE ARE. REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THEY CONSIDER THEMSELVES
NON CONFORMING. THEIR THEIR
APPEARANCE THEIR PRESENTATION
MAY NOT MEET YOUR MY EXPECTATION
OF A PARTICULAR SEX- WERE YEAH I
ALWAYS GET MIXED UP WITH R. C.
GENDER THEIR SEX BUT IF I'M
POLICIES THAT I AM NOT. GETTING
THAT TERMINOLOGY RIGHT BUT IN
OTHER WORDS. YOU MAY BE
PERFECTLY COMFORTABLE AS A MALE
BUT YOUR APPEARANCE DOES NOT
PRESENT TO SOMEBODY ELSE
SOMEBODY ELSE DOESN'T ASSUME.
YOUR MAIL SO YOU MAY NOT VIEW
YOURSELF AS NON CONFORMING AND
THIS OF COURSE WHEN WE HAVE.
KIDS OFTEN FACE THIS END DATE I
REMEMBER MY DAUGHTER'S FRIENDS
OFTEN EXPERIENCING WHERE THEY
WENT INTO A RESTROOM AND WE'RE
TOLD LIKE WHAT ARE YOU WHAT ARE
YOU DOING IN THIS RESTROOM. YOU
SHOULDN'T BE AND THEN THEY WOULD
BE LIKE WHAT YOU KNOW IT SO IT'S
THIS- WE ALL HAVE THESE WE
PROJECT ON TO PEOPLE. THE IT
WILL IT'S NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
PERSON SO WHY WE HAVE THIS
ARBITRARY DISTINCTION. IN OUR
BUILDING CODE REALLY DOESN'T
SERVE ANY OF US AND SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE- THE- COMMENTS BY
THE COMMITTEE THAT BROUGHT INTO
THE BENEFITS OF THE BILL. BEYOND
WHAT THE KEY THINGS THAT REALLY
WE KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT FOR OUR
TRANSGENDER AND NONCONFORMING
FOLKS. AND- I WILL MOVE THE BILL
. ANY OTHER CA THANK YOU YES.
SENATOR CARILLO. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- I JUST WANNA- GO ON RECORD
I'M GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL- I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AND
I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING IT I
GENERALLY DON'T SUPPORT JUMPING
IN FRONT OF OUR- PROCESSES THAT
WE GO THROUGH THROUGH THE-
BUILDING AND STANDARDS CODE-
HAVING SAT ON THAT COMMITTEE I.
I AM. I AM PAINFULLY AWARE OF
THE NEED FOR- THAT DEPARTMENTS
TO DO THE WORK THAT THEY SHOULD
DO THROUGH THE APA- HEARINGS AND
COMMENTS AND- IT'S A FAIRLY
EXTENSIVE PROCESS AND THEN THE
COMMISSION- IT GOES THROUGH THE
ESSENTIALLY THE SAME PROCESS AND
SO IT'S IMPORTANT. BUT I
UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO MOVE THIS
HAPPENED TO DO IT QUICKLY BUT I
WANT TO BE CAREFUL THAT WE DON'T
TAKE AWAY. FROM OUR PROCESS
SEES- THE ABILITY TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS AT THE BUILDING
STANDARDS CODES AND IN THE
DEPARTMENTS AS WELL SO THREE
POINT I WILL I WILL SUPPORT IT
THANK YOU WE STARTED DOING IT
WE'D END UP WITH A MASS LIKE I
THINK. PERSONALLY YOU'RE RIGHT.
ANYONE ELSE. WE DO HAVE A MOTION
BUT PLEASE- SENATOR ALLEN- YOU
MAY CLOSE. THE THOUGHTFULNESS-
YOU KNOW WE ALSO WORK WITH SOME
FOLKS IN THE PLUMBING COMMUNITY
PLUMBERS ATTEMPTED TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS BUT- YEAH.
I THINK THAT THE TWO OF YOU
DIRECTED A GREAT JOB OF SUMMING
UP WHY THIS IS IMPORTANT SO I
WITHOUT A REFRESHING. WITH GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SENATOR
ALAN AND SIGHED DO WE HAVE A
MOTION MOVED BY CITIZENS CORRECT
OKAY GREAT- WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS SENATE BILL ELEVEN
NINETY FOUR BY SENATOR ALAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS SENATOR WIENER
AYE INTER AYE BATES. BATES HI
CABALLERO RIGHT CABALLERO HI
CORTESE MCGUIRE MITCHELL BROKE.
SKINNER SKINNER HI I'M BURKE HI
NUMBER FIVE ACCOUNTS KEEP MY
CASKEY I SIX ZERO THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'LL
PUT THAT ON HOLD THANK YOU- OKAY
OUR FINAL BILL THE DAY IS ITEM
TEN SP TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR BY
CENTER BATES SURVEY TO MAKE-
PRESENTS. RIGHT.
THANK WITH. WELL THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- GOOD MORNING
AND I AM PLEASED OUT TODAY 2% SB
TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR WHICH WILL
WORK TO ALLEVIATE THE HOMELESS
CRISIS BY CREATING ADDITIONAL
PATHWAYS OF AID FOR THE HOMELESS
I'M CALLING IT THE HOMELESS
FIRST PLUS POLICY WHCH HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
TO ALLOW A LITTLE BROADER
INTERPRETATION OF THE OUR
HOUSING POLICY FROM SAN
FRANCISCO TO SAN DIEGO THERE'S
NOT A COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA
THAT HAS GONE UNTOUCHED BY THE
HOMELESS CRISIS SWEEPING THE
STATE. SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA HAS SPENT SEVENTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS ON HOMELESSNESS
ALLEVIATION INITIATIVES THROUGH
FIFTY DIFFERENT PROGRAMS ACROSS
FIFTEEN STATE ENTITIES WHY WE
HAVE BROUGHT OVERWHELMING
FINANCIAL FIRE POWER TO THE
PROBLEM THE PROBLEM HAS GROWN TO
NIGHT OVER ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WILL SLEEP
IN THEIR CARS CANCER OUTSIDE
SIMPLY PUT THIS IS JUST NOT
RIGHT THERE IS SOMETHING WRONG
WITH THIS PICTURE THE CRISIS OF
HOMELESSNESS HAS REACHED SUCH A
MAGNITUDE AND THE SOLUTIONS WE
HAVE TRIED HAVE FAILED AT SUCH A
SCALE WE NEED AND ALL OF THE
ABOVE TYPE APPROACH TO OFFER
FRESH ALTERNATIVES. AS YOU ALL
KNOW IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
CALIFORNIA ADOPTED THE HOUSING
FIRST ONLY MODEL FOR ALL
PROJECTS WITH STATE FUNDING
WHILE I BELIEVE THERE ARE
CERTAINLY MANY CASES WERE
HOUSING FIRST IS THE NECESSARY
AND BENEFICIAL PROGRAM HOWEVER
PRIORITIZING AS THE SINGLE
SOLUTION PERMANENT HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION THAT WON'T BE
USABLE UNTIL THE NEXT STEP
DECADE AT THE EXPENSE OF
CREATING AN OPERATING IN
ASSISTING SHELTERS AND NON
PROFITS WHO INCLUDE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES THAT CAN BRING SPRING
INTO ACTION TODAY IS THE WAY TO
GO. SIX ALLEGE HAS RIGIDLY CLUNG
TO HOUSING FIRST ONLY WITHOUT
PROVIDING THE SLIGHTEST
OPPORTUNITY FOR OTHER SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS. JUST THIS YEAR OUR
COLLEAGUE IN THE OTHER HOUSE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARLOS VIA. WE
DO OUR ROUTE FORTY BUILT WITH
THE SMALLEST OF CARVE OUTS TO
HOUSING FIRST ONLY THE BILL
WOULD HAVE PROOF PROHIBITED
ALCOHOL AND DRUG USE. IN A
DESIGNATED HOUSING ONLY FOR SO
SHELTER FACILITY WHERE CHILDREN
ARE PRESENT IN THE TENET IS
UNDER A COURT ORDER TO REFRAIN
FROM USE OF THOSE SUBSTANCES AS
A CONDITION OF REUNIFICATION
WITH THEIR CHILDREN. THE BILL
COULD NOT EVEN GET A HEARING
DATE SET BECAUSE IT PROVIDED AN
EXCEPTIONTO THE HOUSING FIRST
REQUIREMENT. AND IGNORED THE
NEED FOR A SAFE AND SECURE
ENVIRONMENT FOR OTHER PEOPLE
PARENTS AND CHILDREN WHO ARE CO
LOCATED WITH SOMEONE ENGAGED IN
DRUG OR ALCOHOL MISUSE. FOR
CHILDREN WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED
TRAUMA FROM DRUG AND ALCOHOL
ABUSE THIS ALL IN APPROACH TO
HOUSING FIRST AND HOUSING FIRST
ONLY SUBJECTS SUBJECTS THEM TO
ADDITIONAL ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
TRAUMA. THEY DIDN'T ASK FOR AND
CERTAINLY ARE NONE OF US NEED TO
SEE THAT HAPPEN. FOR EXAMPLE OUR
RIGID APPLICATION OF HOUSING
FIRST POLICY SHOULDN'T BE
SUBJECTING CHILDREN TO MORE
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCES WHEN WE
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE AREAS. WE NEED TO
BE OFFERING MORE OPTIONS NOT
FEWER. CALIFORNIA'S FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE ARE DIVERSE
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN ARE
DIVERSE AND CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESS POPULATION IS EQUALLY
DIVERSE WE MUST PROVIDE. A
PALETTE OF OPTIONS RATHER THAN
FORCE THE SAME. OUR SOLUTIONS ON
EVERY PERSON PROGRAMS AND
SHELTERS THAT REQUIRE
PARTICIPATION IN PROGRAMMING.
AND WRAPAROUND SERVICES SHOULD
NOT BE EXCLUDED FROM AND ALL OF
THE ALL OF THE ABOVE TYPE
APPROACH. AS A FORMER SOCIAL
WORKER MYSELF I CAN TELL YOU
THAT WE KNOW DIFFERENT PEOPLE
HAVE DIFFERENT NEEDS AND WE TRY
TO ADDRESS THOSE OR SOME PEOPLE
ONLY NEED A PLACE TO STAY AT
NIGHT. OTHERS NEED AND WANT
ACCOUNTABILITY THE STATE'S
CURRENT APPROACH CONSTRAINS THE
OPTIONS AND OFFERS THAT THOSE
PEOPLE CAN GET. THAT IS NOT TO
SAY THAT ALL OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S ACTIONS HAVE
FAILED. BACK IN TWENTY NINETEEN
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
SENATOR UMBERG. PASSED SB FOUR
FIFTY WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THAT BILL EXEMPTED MOTELS HOTELS
AND HOSTELS FROM SYKORA IF THE
PROJECT CREATED SUPPORTIVE OR
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING. SB FOUR
FIFTY HELP TO ACCELERATE SHELTER
CONSTRUCTION CUT RED TAPE AND
GOT CALIFORNIANS OFF THE
STREETS. UNFORTUNATELY THAT%
EXEMPTION RUNS OUT AT THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR SB TWELVE R.
EIGHTY FOUR WOULD REMOVE
BARRIERS FOR PROGRAMS THAT DO
NOT CONFORM TO HOUSING FIRST
REGULATIONS. AND ALLOW THEM TO
APPLY FOR STATE FUNDING AND IT
WOULD ALSO EXTEND THE SECRETIVE
SECRET EXEMPTION FOR SUPPORTIVE
AND TRANSITIONAL HOUSING. SO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN PLAN AND
IMPLEMENT SHELTERS WITH
CONFIDENCE. TODAY I AM PLEASED
HAVING SHOW STEVE AS A WITNESS
FOR OVER TWELVE YEARS SHE RAN ST
JOHN'S PROGRAM FOR REAL CHANGE
IN SACRAMENTO. AND TRANSFORMED
AN ORDINARY THIRTY DAY EMERGENCY
SHELTER INTO A ROBUST
COMPREHENSIVE EIGHTEEN MONTH
PROGRAM HELPING HOMELESS WOMEN
AND CHILDREN. SHE HAS ALSO DONE
RESEARCH INTO THE EFFECTIVENESS
. OTHER LACK OF A HOUSING FIRST
ONLY OUR PROGRAM SHE WILL BE
ABLE TO HELP ANSWER QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE IN SPEAK TO WHY A
BROADER APPROACH TO PROVIDE.
GREATER SERVICE ACCESS GREATER
ACCESS TO SERVICES IS NEEDED AND
VERY HUMANE. THANK YOU SENATOR
AND CENTER ON WILL YOU BE-
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN COMMON
TWELVE INCOMING FOURTEEN. AND
JUST ARE COMMON TWELVE- IS- AN
AMENDMENT TO REMOVE THE HOUSING
FIRST ELIMINATION FROM THE BELT
COMMENT FOURTEEN- IT IS ABOUT
THE SEQUEL EXCEPTION IN CHANGE
YET FROM- SUNSET REMOVAL TO A
TWENTY THIRTY SUNSET. ARE YOU
ACCEPTING OF THE MULTI I'M CAN
CAN I REVIEW THOSE WHITE OAK
PLEASE PLEASE. LET ME TAKE A
LOOK.
I'M SORRY I BELIEVE COMMON
CALLING MISTY BUTTONS I BELIEVE
COMMENT FOURTEEN IS ACTION
AUTHOR AMENDMENT COMING TWELVE
AS A COMMITTEE AMENDMENT- SO
ACTUALLY MY QUESTION IS FOR THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT WHICH IS
AND- COMMENT. TWELVE ARE YOU
ACCEPTING THAT AMENDMENT. THAT
NO NOT TWELVE YEAH ARE ONLY ON
THE SEQUEL YES BUTTON ON NOT
WELCOME C. REJECTING THE
COMMITMENT YET THANK YOU IS THAT
RIGHT YES OKAY. OKAY GREAT- SO
YOUR- ARE LEAVING THIS IS-
MICHELLE STEVE FROM SAINT
JOHN'S- IS- MITCHELL STEVE ON
THE LINE. IT YOU. ARE YOU THERE
. I AM OKAY YOU MAY I PROCEED
THAT BETTER YES WE CAN WE CAN
HEAR YOUR BILL. OKAY THERE'S A
LOT OF BACKGROUND NOISE ON THE
LINE. NOT FROM MY END AT- WE CAN
HEAR YOU CLEARLY. OKAY WELL
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE
HERE TODAY BECAUSE PART OF AT
THE OF EIGHTY FOUR AND THE SOUTH
OF THE CALIFORNIANS STRUGGLING
WITH HOMELESSNESS. EIGHT AND
THIRTEEN YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
RUNNING ONE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST PROGRAMS
FOR HOMELESS WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
I CREATED A HEALTH CARE FOR THE
BUCK I RECENTLY AUTHORED CALLED
ANSWERED BEHIND RED DOOR I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN WITH THIS. IS
DIAGRAMS TODAY IF IT IN FRONT OF
YOU. BECAUSE TO TELL OF THE
FALCON AT ALL TO FULFILL IS THE
TIRE CAL. YEAH THE FREEWAYS FOR
SLEEPING IN THE PARK. THE STOCK
APPRECIATED THIS OUT OF. AT
UNDER THIRTY. OF THE STRUGGLE
WITH MENTAL ON VERY. AS POLICY
LAPSE OUT THE NIGHT IN FOUND
THAT HAVE. EIGHT OF THE AND
SHELTERED STRUCK WITH I DON'T
KNOW. AND 75% THIS. IS THE- OR
TAKE. HE'S ALIGN WITH EXPERIENCE
AND RUN THINGS NINE. PUBLIC FOR
IS THAT THE CRIME THINK
CONSTITUTE THE MAJORITY OF THE
HOME POPULATION BECAUSE THEY
TEND TO GIVE THEM A DIFFICULT.
HOWEVER IT OUR OUR- IF YOU LOOK
AT THE L. ON THE LEFT SIDE OF
HER THE FINANCING HOMELESS ACON
IT'S BETWEEN HANDY TWENTY PER OF
THE NAY OVER FROM POPULATION ON
THE RATE THAT WHICH EIGHT YEARS
BROUGH THEIR MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
ILLNESS AND FOR AND ARE OFTEN
LIVING ON THE- BUT NOT A- HOW
FIRST. AND THE MOST OF IT I BUT
THE FACT THAT THEY'RE RIGHT AT
INCREASE THE ENCOURAGE ROLLOUT
AND I RETURN AT THIS POINT
VETERANS REASON H. AND.
APLYSIA SITUATIONS THEY AFFECT
THE RE ENTERED THE ACT. STRAINS
OF BRUCELLA. PROVIDING THEM WITH
LIFELONG UPSIDE HOUSING IS NOT.
THE MIDDLE OF. FORTY OF HEALTH
OF OUR PEOPLE STRUGGLING OF OUR
OUR HOMELESS STRUGGLING WITH I
ADDRESS ON OCT RESULT IN AT THIS
IS. AND MENTAL IN. DOES LET THE
FEAR FORM AND THOSE WITH CHRONIC
THOSE AND THE WONDERFUL LET'S
POPULATE AND. ROBERT AT THE SAME
TIME TO DEMONSTRATE THAT THE
PROPERTY CENTER AND THEN THE
DISEASE'S THE PERFECT POPULATION
STRUGGLES. AND GET THE- ST
EDWARD. ALLOWING THEM TO WORK IN
A FEW OUT THE PHOENIX. THE
PROVISION OF LIFELONG THAT'S
WHAT I HAVE FOR THIS. GIVEN
POTENTIAL BECOME ABLE. IT'S ALSO
AT THE VERY IT- FOR THE STRAIGHT
JACKET. YOU CAN TO HARM AND
THEY'RE STILL IF THEY HAVE THAT
. AS ABLE TO ENGAGE IN THE- THAT
LED TO ME. THAT. LIFELONG LIFE
HAS WITHOUT CONDITIONS ALLTEL
FROM IS NOT ONLY ON REAL IF
HELLO LACK OF HOUSING IS GREAT
HEY. ANNA THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE
THANK YOU FOR THE REAR OF IT IS
HE'S THE EIGHT THANK YOU ALREADY
OF THE HOMELESS POPULATION THOSE
IN THE MIDDLE.
THE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TESTIMONY
ON THE PHONE LINES. YES THEY DID
GERMANY YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME
. OKAY IF YOU LIKE WE SHOULD
VOTE FOR THE FIRST ONE ZERO AT.
THEY CURRENTLY HAVE BOTH PARTIES
FEEL GROWTH. OKAY COM WE WILL
NOW GO TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE TO
THE OPPONENT- TO THE OPPONENTS
SHARON REPORT AND ZACHARY- WARM
UP- AND THIS REPORT IS HERE I
THINK- SORRY WHAT WAS ON THE
PHONE. THIS REPORT GOOD MORNING
SHARON REPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND HOUSING CALIFORNIA A
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
CHANGES TO CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
FIRST LAW THAT WOULD BE MPOSED
AND SB TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR. UNDER
S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING FIRST LAWS
WOULD BE NULLIFIED. UNDER THIS
BILL A GOOD PROGRAM FUNDED NOW
COULD LOSE FUTURE FUNDING TO A
LESS EFFECTIVE PROGRAM. UNDER
THIS BILL SOMEONE LIVING IN
STATE FUNDED HOUSING COULD BE
EVICTED TO HOMELESSNESS IF THEY
RELAPSE EVEN THOUGH EVIDENCE
SHOWS THAT RELAPSE IS A VERY
NORMAL PART OF RECOVERY. WITHOUT
A LEASE PEOPLE WOULD BE LEFT
WITHOUT PROTECTIONS REFLECTION
AFFORDED BY OUR CALIFORNIA LAWS
IN MANY OF THE HOUSING PROGRAMS
. CALIFORNIANS COULD BE DENIED
HOUSING UNTIL THEY ACHIEVE
SOBRIETY EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW
PEOPLE CANNOT GET SOBER WHILE
STILL HOMELESS. THEY COULD BE
DENIED HOUSING BECAUSE THE STATE
FUNDED HOUSING PROGRAM BELIEVES
THEY AREN'T READY OR THEY
HAVEN'T STAYED LONG ENOUGH AND
SHELTER. UNDER THIS BILL A
CALIFORNIANS LIVING IN STATE
FUNDED HOUSING COULD RETURN TO
HOMELESSNESS AFTER SIX MONTHS
BECAUSE THE PROGRAM ONLY LASTS
SIX MONTHS. THE STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES WOULD
HAVE DIFFERENT POLICIES WITH
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS AND
LOCALS WOULD HAVE TO NAVIGATE
AND EVEN MORE SILENT STATE
RESPONSE. BEFORE THE STATE
ADOPTED THE HOUSING FIRST LOSS
STATE FUNDED PROGRAMS RETURN
PEOPLE HOME UP TO HOMELESSNESS
FREQUENTLY USING TAXPAYER MONEY
FOR THOSE PROGRAMS. REPUBLICAN
ANDDEMOCRATIC ADMINISTRATIONS
IN STATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
NATIONALLY HAVE ADOPTED HOUSING
FIRST AS THE ONLY APPROACH FOR
ONE REASON IT WORKS IT IS THE
ONLY MODEL THAT HAS BEEN PROVEN
TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS. AND IT
IS THE ONLY MODEL PROVEN TO
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM RETURNING TO
HOMELESSNESS IT ALSO HAPPENS TO
BE THE LEAST EXPENSIVE MODEL. AS
WE HAVE SEEN BEFORE THE PASSAGE
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF S. B. FOOD
THIRTEEN EIGHTY HOMELESSNESS HAS
BEEN INCREASING THANKS TWO
HUNDRED AND 16% INCREASE AND
RENTS IN CALIFORNIA OVER THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS. HOWEVER LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ARE HOPING MORE
CALIFORNIANS EXIT HOMELESSNESS
PERMANENTLY SINCE THE PASSAGE OF
THIS LAW. FOR THESE REASONS I
URGE A NO VOTE ON M. S. B.
TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR TO PREVENT
ONE ANECDOTAL STORY OF ONE
PROGRAM FROM TURNING BACK THE
CLOCK ON PROGRESS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU WILL NOW GO TO
ZACHARY WARM- THAT WAS- YOU
HAVE- EXCUSE ME A MINUTE AND
FORTY SECONDS. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN HONORABLE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ACTUALLY WARMER AND I
DID IT CORRECTLY ALL OF IT AND
WE HAVE THE LARGEST PUBLIC
SERVICE FOR FIVE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS ALEX. EIGHT
FOR MISSION HOW PEOPLE TWENTY
OUT OF HOMELESSNESS POPPY BURKE
HIM OF HOW TO GET THE WITH
FORRESTER. WE OPERATE ARRAY OF
HOUSING AND URBAN INCLUDING.
CALPERS AND RUN SUPPORTIVE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
INDIVIDUALS YEAH. INCLUDING
WOMEN AND CHILDREN THE STOCK OF
IF THE DOOR. IF YOU CAN
RESOUNDING. AT TWELVE EIGHTY
FOUR PROPOSAL OF HOUSING FOR.
WHICH IS AN ACT WOULD BE A
COMMAND A FOR THE STATE OF THE-
ART WORK LEN EIGHT BUT BELIEF IN
. AN APPLE ABOUT OUTLOOK FOR.
HAVE BEEN FIFTY PROTESTS ON THE
MONTHLY RECOGNIZE. HAVING A ABLE
TO ROOF OVER ONE AT THE SPECIAL
FIRST THAT FIRST BEGINNING FOR.
I THINK CRITICAL AT. BROWN FROM
PARENTS ARE REDUCTION AND-
SHOULD NEEDS INTO. I WOULD
UNNECESSARY. FOR ANY OUT. WE'LL
HAVE A REPORT. EVIDENCE NUMBER
THAT HOUSING FIRST ALL WORK.
MITCHELL SOMEHOW AFTER FORTY
EIGHT HOURS. AT A HIGHER. AND
MOST CRITICALLY MORE LIKE FOR ME
ABLE TO TAP. FORTY THREE THAT
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX HOUSING FOR
BLOCK OF MAIN STREET AND MARK.
LEGISLATION ENSURING ACTIVE
PROGRESSIVE IN.
AND TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS I.
BEING ABLE TO AFFORD A HOUSE THE
LAST THING WE SHOULD BE DOING OR
FORTY SIX ORDER NUMBER PROBABLE
BUT FROM. THE COME UP READ AN
INFILL HOME. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST A NO VOTE ON BEFORE BUT-
THANK YOU YOUR TIME. OKAY YOU
VERY. OUR IS ANY OF THIS OFFICES
IN HEARING ROOM COME FOR. WITH
ANYA LAWLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA OVERLY ASSISTANCE.
AND THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY OPPOSITION. ANYONE
ELSE WHO'S COME FORWARD. IN
OPPOSITION OKAY SAY NINE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES.
THESE JANICE YOU ARE NOT
POSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO IN OPPOSITION. AT
THE TIME WE HAVE NO PARTY THANK
YOU OKAY THANK YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE OF ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS COLLEAGUES
- SENATOR JOE BOCANEGRA CENTER
CABALLERO. I JUST HAD A QUESTION
AND I APOLOGIZE THEY CAME IN
LATE I'M TRYING TO MANAGE THREE
COMMITTEES THIS MORNING SPOKE
ABOUT THE SAME TIME SORRY- IF
IT'S ALREADY BEEN SAID I
APOLOGIZE- I HAD A QUESTION WITH
REGARDS TO YOU I HAVE. THIS
DIAGRAM IN WHICH IT- EXPLAINS
SOME OF THE- CHALLENGES THAT THE
HOUSING FIRST HAD AND HOW IT'S
BACKFIRED BUT I'M KIND OF
CURIOUS BECAUSE- MY ANDERSON
THIS CAME FROM HYDE BUT WE HAD
A- LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
SAYING HERE THAT IT'S BEEN
PROVEN TO BE EFFECTIVE SO I
WANNA UNDERSTAND THE DISCREPANCY
BETWEEN THE STATEMENT THAT WAS
MADE BY THE LEAD OPPOSITION AND
THE- AND THE HIDE GRAPH. THAT WE
HAVE. MAY I IN FACT THAT WAS THE
- SO YOUR QUESTION WAS TO THE
LEAD OPPOSITION YES THERE WAS
ONE OF THE MAIN OPPOSITION-
MAKING STATEMENTS TO THE FACT
THAT HOUSING FIRST HAD BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE OKAY THAT WAS IN THIS
REPORT THIS REPORT SO MISTER
BRIDGEMAN RESPONDS CENTER CHOI
BOGUE. YES I'M SORRY I HAVEN'T
SEEN THIS BEFORE SO- I THINK IN
GENERAL I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY.
THE TITLE OF IT BUT GENERALLY-
NATIONALLY- WE HAVE ADOPTED
HOUSING FIRST AS THE FEDERAL
POLICY- FEDERAL HOMELESS
RESPONSE- AND HOMELESSNESS HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY DECREASED IF YOU
LOOK AT THE TIME THAT THAT
HAPPENS AND NOW IS THE INCREASE
BY AT LEAST 10% OF THANK YOU.
AND SO I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE
GRAPH. IS SHOWING WITHOUT
LOOKING AT A LITTLE BIT MORE
CLOSELY BUT WE HAVE ACTUALLY
DECREASED HOMELESSNESS. IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
HOMELESSNESS HAS INCREASED IN
CALIFORNIA- DESPITE ADOPTION OF
HOUSING FIRST BUT THAT WAS WE
WERE ON THAT TRAJECTORY ARE
READY BEFORE. HOUSING FIRST WAS
ADOPTED- IT'S ONLY BEEN
IMPLEMENTED SINCE TWENTY
NINETEEN SO- I THINK THE ONLY
REASON WHY FEDERAL HOMELESSNESS
IS INCREASING IS ACTUALLY
BECAUSE OF CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE
OUR HOUSING COSTS ARE SO HIGH SO
I'M THE GRAPHIC SHE HAS BOTH THE
FEDERAL AS A FEDERAL GRAPH HERE
AND IT ALSO HAS A CALIFORNIA SO
I'M JUST GONNA USE IN THE
CALIFORNIA PART OF IT. NOT AS
MUCH- I MEAN WE SHOULD. ACTUALLY
NOW WE'RE REFERENCING CALIFORNIA
SO I AM MOSTLY INTERESTED IN
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND- YOUR- YOUR
VERSION AND UNDERSTANDING OF THE
SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAM AND HIDES
INTERPRETATION. OF THE- WHAT
THEY EXPRESS ARE AND I'M QUOTING
THE- JUST REFERENCING THIS
DIAGRAM THE ADDAMS. THE FAILED
EXPERIMENT AND- AND SECOND TO
THAT I'M I'M ALSO KIND OF
CURIOUS TO UNDERSTAND- THE END
OF THE PROGRAM IS ONLY BE
INSTITUTED SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETEEN IN YOUR EXPERIENCE-
IN THIS SPACE HOW LONG SHOULD
WE- LOOK TO THE PROGRAM TO SEE
OR TO JUSTIFY ITS SUCCESS OR
FAILURE. ON ON THIS TYPE OF
PROGRAM- WELL THOSE ARE
EXCELLENT QUESTIONS I THINK THAT
AGAIN NATIONALLY HOMELESSNESS
HAS DECREASED SINCE
IMPLEMENTATION OF HOUSING FOR SO
AGAIN I WOULD HAVE TO LOOK AT
THIS A LITTLE BIT MORE CLOSELY
BECAUSE I HAVEN'T LOOKED AT IT
BEFORE- BUT IT HAS DECREASED IF
YOU LOOK AT THE HOMELESS
NUMBERS. WHEN IT WAS ADOPTED
INTO A IN TWO THOUSAND SIX OR
SEVEN NATIONALLY HOMELESSNESS
HAS SIGNIFICANTLY GONE DOWN-
OVER THOSE YEARS CALIFORNIA I
CANNOT ALREADY MA'AM I WANT TO
FOCUS IN CALIFORNIA- I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A
WITNESS ON THE PHONE- ONLINE
THAT COULD POSSIBLY HAVE. THE
ABILITY TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
AS WELL. IF IT THROUGH THE JACK
THAT WOULD BE POSSIBLE HEALTH.
YES YOU CAN YEAH YOU CAN. ASK A
QUESTION A MISDEED- MISTY DID
YOU HAVE A QUESTION. HE WOULD
LIKE ME TO ADDRESS THE
CALIFORNIA ART THE FIFTEEN.
SHE'S A SHE'S ASKING ABOUT
GRAPHICS THAT HAVE BEEN
DISTRIBUTED OUT I'M A I WILL
HAVE SOME COMMENTS ON THESE ARE
GRAPHICS AFTERWARDS THAT SOME
OPINIONS ABOUT THESE GRAPHICS
BUT- THE I THINK OUR CENTER CHAU
BOGUS ASK YOU TO COMMENT. ON
THOSE GRAPHICS. YES THAT THAT
THE GRAPH BOTH CHAU PRE CODED HI
A HARD DATA IN YOUR HOME WITH
THIS IS THAT REPORT. IT IS A
COMBINATION OF FIVE THAT'S A
HARD DATA USUALLY WHEN WE SEE A
HARD DATA IT IS ONE WORK USE
THAT. ASSISTANCE HI DAVID THIS
IS THE FIFTH REVENUE QUESTION
ABOUT THE FATE AT THE QUESTION
IS THE DIRECTED TO HAS. THE
REASON WE USE CREEK PROBATE IS
SO. THE THERE HAVE NOT BEEN ANY
. REALLY CANCEL POUNDS COALBED
THAT COULD REALLY NEED TO LOOK
AT THIS OF THREE COKE ED AND
WHAT IT SHOWS IS THAT THE
FEDERAL. I INCREASE HOMELESS AS
BUT MY AND FEAR. AND INCREASED
HOMELESS. UNDER WITH IN. HOUSE
FIRST THANK YOU. SIXTEEN BUT
THEN ADDED IN THAT YOU FOUND.
THIS ONE TWO THOUSAND. THERE WAS
A FORTY SEVEN POINT 1% INCREASE
ON THE AND SHELTER. OF THIRTY
THREE POINT 8% INCREASE. IN THE
OVERALL HOMELESS POPULATION
AGAIN TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN. EVEN THOUGH- WE
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF TERMINATE
PORT OF HOUSING UNITS DEDICATED
TO THE HOMELESS I THIRTY THREE
PERCENT. FOR ANYONE TO SAY THAT
HOMELESSNESS IS GONE DOWN IN
CALIFORNIA THE END OR AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL THEY NEED TO LOOK
AT THE START IT IS HI DAY THAT.
YOU'RE A BEAUTIFUL HIGH DATA-
THAT YOU CAN DOES. NO QUESTION
HAD ABOUT- OKAY THANK YOU VERIFY
COULD. LOOK AT THE- TALKING A
LITTLE BIT MORE. YEAH YOU HAVE
TO DO ON I'M GONNA BE ADDRESSING
AS WELL- IF YOU WANT TO SIGN
BRIEFLY I WAS JUST GOING TO
MENTION IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THE SPEAKER WAS TALKING ABOUT
HOW HOMELESSNESS IS INCREASE
THAT THE LEGISLATION DIDN'T
ACTUALLY BECOME EFFECTIVE UNTIL
JANUARY TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AND WASN'T ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED
UNTIL TWENTY NINETEEN IT GAVE TO
AGENCIES TWO YEARS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR OUR FIND THAT. JUST
REALLY QUICK SENATOR- WIENER
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT NAY MAKE A
MOTION I THEY'RE CLOSING MY
OTHER COMMITTEE YEAH SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE THE MOTION BEFORE YOU
LEAVE IS THAT OKAY OKAY ARE YOU
GONNA BE BACK TO VOTE I WILL BE
BACK TO VOTE THEY'RE JUST OUT
THERE AT THE VERY VERY THEY'RE
JUMPING FROM HER SHE MADE A
MOTION AND- I APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU. I ANY OTHER OR-
CENTER CABALLERO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WELL I WANNA- THANK
MICHELLE STEEP FOR- HER. WORK IN
THIS AREA- I'M VERY FAMILIAR
WITH SAINT JOHN AND- THE WORK
THAT THEY DO AND- IT'S AN
INCREDIBLE ORGANIZATION- I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
THEY DO BECAUSE NOT ONLY ARE
THEY TAKING WOMEN AND THEIR
CHILDREN OFF THE STREETS BUT-
THEIR- TEACHING THEM A TRADE
AND- THAT'S REALLY PART OF THIS
SOLUTION FOR HOMELESSNESS IS TO
BE ABLE TO GET. A JOB AND-
SUPPORT YOURSELF AND MOVE INTO
YOUR TO HOUSING- ON YOUR OWN-
AWAY FROM THE FACILITY SO I
THINK SHE DOES REALLY TREMENDOUS
WORK AND I KNOW THAT.THE
CHALLENGE WITH THE ORGANIZATION
IS THAT- AND THEY THEY THEY- ONE
OF THE JOB- SKILLS IS THAT
WORKING IN THE- IN THE CHECK BE
IN THE- FOOD SERVICE INDUSTRY
AND SO THEY THEY RUN A KITCHEN
AND- AND THEY HAVE FUND RAISERS
FOR THE WOMEN ACTUALLY WORK AND-
AND- SHOW YOU THEIR SKILLS IT'S
REALLY IMPRESSIVE- SO IT'S
ALWAYS GOOD TO HEAR FROM HER-
THE- THE CHALLENGES THEY CAN
ACCESS ANY STATE RESOURCES
BECAUSE- OF THAT HOUSING FIRST
AND THEY HAVE A- REQUIREMENTS
BECAUSE THEY HOUSE CHILDREN IN
THEIR FACILITY THEY HAVE
REQUIREMENTS THAT. NO DRUGS OR
ALCOHOL- IN THE PROGRAM AND THEY
DO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION- A
RELAPSE RELAPSING BECAUSE THAT'S
PART OF THE- PART OF THE
TREATMENT IS UNDERSTANDING THAT
RELAPSES OCCUR AND SO- I AM VERY
SENSITIVE TO THAT NEED TO BE
ABLE TO FIND SOMETHING- OTHER
THAN HOST HOUSING FIRST- I'M NOT
SURE THIS IS. THIS IS THE WAY TO
DO IT WHICH IS TO- ELIMINATED AS
AS THE PRIMARY PROGRAMS- BUT I
BUT I DO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
SOME PROGRAMS THAT- THAT IF WE
LOOKED AT THEM THROUGH THE LENS
OF SUCCESS WE'D BE ABLE TO SAY
THAT THAT THEY'RE SUCCESSFUL
AND- AND THAT THEY ACHIEVE THE
GOALS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO REACH
WHICH IS TO GET PEOPLE INTO
PERMANENT HOUSING- SO. I AM I
CANNOT SUPPORT THE BILL HERE
TODAY THE WAY IT'S WRITTEN- BUT
I CERTAINLY WOULD SUPPORT A
CARVE OUT OF THE PROGRAM FOR
THOSE PROGRAMS THAT THAT CAN
PROVE THAT THEIR- EVIDENCE BASED
IN THAT THERE'S THAT- A SUCCESS
RATE DOWN THAT. THAT DOWN THE
ROAD I'M I'M FRUSTRATED WITH
SOME OF OUR HOUSING- ARE
HOMELESS- PROGRAMS BECAUSE WE
REALLY DON'T HAVE A REAL GOOD
ANALYSIS OF HOW LONG PEOPLE ARE.
ARE OUT OF HOMELESSNESS AND
WHETHER THEY END UP FALLING BACK
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T PROVIDED THE
SKILLS OR THAT- THE PROGRAMMING
NECESSARY DID TO ENSURE THAT
THEY WILL BE BACK ON ON THE
STREETS WITHIN- A REAL SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME- I. SO AND SO. I
WISH YOU WOULD TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS HAVE BECAUSE I ALSO
LIKE SEE WHAT- EXEMPTION OR THEY
SEE QUICK EXTENSION- BUT HAVING
SAID THAT I. AM THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I YOU
CENTER SKINNER. I'M THANK YOU-
CHEER AND- I WANTED SOME OF THE
COMMENTS SENATOR KABIR MADE.
THAT YOU KNOW THE IT MAY BE VERY
IMPORTANT AND NECESSARY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE SOME TWEAKS
WHETHER IT'S TO HOUSING FIRST OR
ANOTHER OF OUR POLICIES GIVEN
THAT WE HAVE. WE ARE VERY
COMMITTED TO WE'VE ALREADY BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASING OUR
FINANCIAL COMMITMENT TO ADDRESS-
THE PROBLEMS OF HOMELESSNESS.
AND WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
AND OF COURSE WE DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR MONEY IS BEING
SPENT IN A WAY THAT ALLOWS US TO
REALLY ADDRESS THE PROBLEM. BUT
I THINK IT'S MORE COMPLICATED.
THAN THAN THIS BILL. PRESENTS IN
TERMS OF THE SOLUTION. AND AND-
AT I GUESS WHAT I WOULD ASK IS
THAT AND I KNOW THAT OUR AND
CHEER HAS A GREAT INTEREST IN
THIS THAT WE AT SOME POINT WHEN
WE'RE NOT IN THE MIDDLE OF TRIED
TO DO BILLS THAT WE PERHAPS HAVE
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING SO WE
CAN BEGIN TO FLASH SOME OF THESE
THINGS SOUND IF THERE'S
APPROPRIATE ADJUSTMENTS TO MAKE
AND IT MAY NOT BE TO HOUSING
FIRST MAYBE TO ANOTHER ONE OF
OUR PROGRAMS WITH THAT WE
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR THIS. BUT
ANYWAY- I DON'T THINK THAT THIS
IS THE ANSWER AND I APPRECIATED
THE COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS AND
THEIR SUGGESTIONS BUT AGAIN AS-
THE IT'S THE BILL WOULD BE AS IT
IS I WILL NOT BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
. THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER SINGH
NO OTHER- MIKE'S RAISED- SO I
CENTER BATES APPRECIATE YOUR-
YOUR FOLKS YOUR PERSISTENCE AND
FISHER THANK YOU HAD A BILL A
FEW YEARS AGO AS WELL AND WHEN I
WAS CHAIRING THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE- WITHOUT THE AMENDMENT
AS- AS YOU AND I DISCUSSED I
CAN'T SUPPORT THIS BILL. IF THIS
WERE LIMITED TO THIS EXTENSION
OF THE SEQUEL EXAM EXAMS I WOULD
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT I- BUT
THE ELIMINATION OF HOUSING FIRST
AS A CRITIC AS A NO CORNERSTONE.
OF OUR HOUSING POLICY IS JUST
NOT SOMETHING THAT I CAN-
SUPPORT- I DO NOT REALLY TAKE
ISSUE WITH THIS GRAPHIC THAT WE
BEEN DISTRIBUTED THIS IS- I
THINK THAT'S TO BE BLIND  THINK
IT'S MISLEADING- THAT IT'S A
CLASSIC CASE OF- CORRELATION
VERSUS. CAUSATION TO THE SICK I
DON'T KNOW JUST BECAUSE HOUSING
FIRST WAS ADOPTED IN CERTAIN
YEAR EVEN THOSE YOU KNOW WASN'T
EVEN IMPLEMENTED A FEW YEARS
LATER. AND HOMES IS GOING UP
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT HOUSING
FIRST BECAUSE HOMELESSNESS TO GO
OUT- I THERE'S NO INDICATION THE
HOUSING FIRST BECAUSE
HOMELESSNESS- TO GO UP HOUSING
FIRST PREVENTS PEOPLE FROM
BECOMING A RELAXING ON THE
HOMELESSNESS OF WHAT HAS BEEN
HAPPENING THE LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS IS THAT CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES. ON TO FALL FURTHER
AND FURTHER BEHIND OUR NEEDED
HEALTH STOCK- WE RANK FORTY NINE
OUT OF FIFTY STATES AND HOMES
FOR CAPITAL WE'RE SHORT
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TWO AND A HALF
AND THREE AND A HALF MILLION
HOMES WERE PRODUCING EACH YEAR
APPROXIMATELY 50% OF THE HOMES
THAT WE NEED TO BE PRODUCING.
EVERY YEAR COMMUNITIES AROUND
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO OBSTRUCT
THE CREATION OF NEW HOUSING
CONTINUE TO VIOLATE STATE LAW
BRAZENLY. CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR
LOOPHOLES. OUR CONTINUE TO DO
THINGS. LIKE- PROCLAIM THEIR
CITY BE I'M MALE AND LION
HABITAT WORD A PRICKLY THEIR
ENTIRE C. TO BE RISE TO.
DISTRICT OR ANY OTHER NUMBER OF
SHENANIGANS THAT CITIES ARE
USING. TO AVOID- CREATING
HOUSING- THAT'S WHY HOMELESS
NUMBERS RE GOING UP BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH HOUSING PERIOD
. IT'S NOT BECAUSE OF HOUSING
FIRST BECAUSE WE'RE NOT BUILDING
ENOUGH HOUSING AT EVERY INCOME
LEVEL- AND SO WE NEED TO LOOK IN
THE MIRROR AND- DECIDE IF WE
REALLY ARE COMMITTED. TO
PRIORITIZING. THE BASIC CONCEPT
THAT WISH THAT EVERYONE SHOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO A HOME- I HAVE
NOTHING AGAINST SAINT JOHN I'VE
ONLY HEARD GOOD THINGS ABOUT
SOME OF THE WORK THAT THEY'VE
DONE- AND SAINT JOHN CAN
CONTINUE WITH THAT SMALL HOUSING
WE DON'T BAN. ORGANIZATIONS FROM
HAVING WE OR DON'T WE DON'T
MANDATE THAT ALL HOUSING- FOR
ALL NONPROFITS HAVE TO BE
HOUSING FIRST. BUT IF YOU WANT
TO GET STATE FUNDING YOU HAVE TO
BE AND YOU CAN'T TAKE SOMEONE
OUT ON THE STREET BECAUSE THE
RELAPSE. THAT'S CALIFORNIA
HOUSING POLICY. BECAUSE PEOPLE
DO RELAPSE WE DON'T WANT THEM TO
RELAPSE BUT IF THEY DO. THEY
SHOULD HAVE BECOME HOMELESS AS A
RESULT THAT DOESN'T BENEFIT
ANYONE. IT MAKES IT HARDER TO RE
HOUSE- IT INCREASES TAXPAYER
COSTS. AND SO ON AND SO FORTH-
SO UNFORTUNATELY WITHOUT- THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE REQUESTED- I
WILL BE OPPOSING- THE BILL
TODAY- AND- SENATOR YOU MAY
CLOSE. I THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR ALL THE DISCUSSION AND
CERTAINLY IT DEBATING OF. THE
STATISTICS THAT SHOW UP ON. A
FARM. AS AS WE HAVE HERE THE FOB
. ANALYSIS OBVIOUSLY YOU CAN'T
JUST AUTOMATICALLY SAY THAT THAT
IS CAUSE AND EFFECT AND I DIDN'T
MEAN IT TO BE INCLUDED BUT IT
CERTAINLY SHOWS THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING AN INCREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS AND WITH THE
HOMELESS ENOUGH FIRST UP PLUS
POLICY I THINK WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE VERY
TRAGIC THINGS THAT HAPPENED
ENOUGH FACILITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED AND HAVE RESIDENTS
THAT ARE. ARE SPECIFICALLY- WITH
ISSUES AYE AYE I'D LIKE TO REFER
TO AN ARTICLE THAT APPEARED
RECENTLY IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
CHRONICLE I BELIEVE WE'RE- IN
THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO ALONE
MORE THAN TEN PEOPLE A MONTH
THAT WERE IN CITY SUPPORTING
HOUSING FACILITIES AND SHELTER
IN PLACE. HOTELS AND THESE ARE
HOUSING FIRST POLICY FACILITIES
IN TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE DIED OF DRUG
OVERDOSES BECAUSE THERE WAS
NOTHING THERE SUPPORTIVE. ARM
I'D LIKE TO LET YOU KNOW THAT
THIS BILL IN THE APPROACH I'M
TAKING HERE IS NOT TO ELIMINATE
HOUSING FIRST AYE. I THINK
THERE'S WAYS TO SET A FINANCIAL-
COMPONENT INTO A BILL LIKE THIS
THAT WOULD SUGGEST THAT IT A
PILOT PROJECT- HOUSING FIRST
PLUS FACILITIES WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE TAX DOLLARS AND HOUSING
FIRST ONLY. ARE THERE- THEIR
FINANCIAL GRANTS WOULD NOT BE
IMPACTED THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
HAVE TO BE LOOKED OUT AND I
WOULD HOPE I WOULD HAVE HOPED
THAT GOING FORWARD IF I DON'T
HAVE THE VOTES WE COULD. WE
COULD BE ADDRESSING SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS BECAUSE IT IS
CLEARLY NOT AN ATTEMPT TO YEAH.
S. FIRST POLICY AS A PLEASURE- I
ACTUALLY PARTICIPATED IN THAT
BEFORE IT WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
A STATE POLICY BECAUSE I- THERE
WAS ONE OF THE DIRECTORS SOB. IN
THE GENERAL RELIEF PROGRAM AS IT
WAS CALLED WE WERE FREQUENTLY
GIVING HOUSING VOUCHERS TO PUT
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS AND HAD
ALCOHOLIC DICTION IN INTO
SINGLE. OUR RESIDENTS ONLY
FACILITIES AND DOWN REFERRING
THEM TO A VARIETY OF. COMMUNITY
ARE BASED- TREATMENT FACILITIES
AND MANY OF THOSE THEY NEVER
ATTENDED AND THAT'S PART OF THE
PROBLEM IF YOU HAVE AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO SAYS I'VE GOT A
PROBLEM AND I NEED
ACCOUNTABILITY I NEED TO BE IN A
FACILITY THAT WILL HELP ME
ACHIEVE. ALL THE THINGS THAT.
THING FIRST PLUS WOULD PROVIDE
AND LET ME SHARE THOSE YOU GET
MENTAL. CIRCLE HEALTH TREATMENT
TO GET LIFE SKILLS PARENTING
SKILLS JOB EDUCATION JOB
TRAINING HOW TO DRESS HOW TO
INTERVIEW AT CETERA. AND THESE
ARE THINGS THAT SHOULD NOT BE
DENIED SOMEONE WHO SELLS I NEED
TO HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY I WANT TO
BE SOMEWHERE. WHERE I CAN
RECEIVE THIS AND WE ARE ACTUALLY
ELIMINATING FACILITIES THAT
PROVIDE THAT BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
BE FUNDED SO I THINK WE SHOULD
TAKE THAT UNDER CONSIDERATION.
AND PROVIDE A WAY THAT HOUSING
FIRST ONLY IS FUNDED FOR THOSE
AND I WOULD SAY THERE'S WHAT- I
THINK THE STATISTICS SHOW ABOUT
34% OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
HOMELESS OUT THERE IT'S AN
ECONOMIC. ISSUE THEY LOST THEIR
JOB AGE VETERANS RETURNING
WHATEVER BUT 74% IN THE THIRD.
GOING BACK TO THE CHARTS THAT
SHOW. YOU KNOW HOW HOW IT'S
GROWN THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES AND
THEY'RE IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. AND I SUGGEST THAT
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NEED ANOTHER TOOL.
HOUSING ONLY PLUS HOUSING FIRST
PLUS POLICY WOULD ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO MAKE. ARE A HUGE
IMPACT I BELIEVE YESTERDAY THE
MAYORS OF LARGE CITIES ACTUALLY
APPEALED FOR SOMETHING LIKE
THIS. SO I'M JUST ASKING US TO
TAKE A SECOND LOOK. MAYBE NOT IN
THIS ROUND BUT GOING FORWARD IF
SOMETHING I THINK IS REALLY
VITAL TO REALLY GETTING AT THE
HEART OF OUR HOMELESS PROBLEM.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE WE ALL
ARE ALL OF US IN THIS ROOM WOULD
LOVE TO AND HOMELESS. ENOUGH NO
QUESTION. AND THERE ARE OTHER
HOT. TECHNIQUES THERE ARE OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ACHIEVING THAT
AND WE SHOULD EMBRACE THOSE THAT
SHOULD NOT BE A SINGLE. APPROACH
ONLY BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE AFRAID
THAT THEY'RE OING TO LOSE OUR
FUNDING ON THAT THAT WOULD NOT
GO AWAY. SO WITHOUT TOM I THANK
YOU FOR THE ROBUST DEBATE WE'VE
HAD IN HERE AND CERTAINLY ALSO.
IN THE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
WHICH IT DID MAKE IT OUT- I WAS
HOPING WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE THAT SPENT TIME. ARE
SINCE OUR CHAIRMAN IS STILL
QUESTIONING AT- MAYBE IT WON'T
THAT TIME WITHOUT A CLOSE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTING YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU CENTER BREAK I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT HOUSING FIRST DOES
ALLOW FOR SOBER LIVING. HOUSING
YOU SIMPLY CAN'T PICK SOMEONE IF
THEY IF THEY RELAPSE BUT I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE A DIFFERENCE
ON THAT I RESPECT YOUR POSITION
ON IT. OKAY WITHOUT SAID WE DIS
CENTER CHOI BO DID MAKE A MOTION
WHICH I'M CONSTRUING AS A MOTION
TO. PASS A BILL WITH THE AUTHOR
AMENDMENT AND WITHOUT THE
COMMITTEE- AMENDMENTS. ABOUT
OSHA. AND WITH THAT WE WILL
CALL. THE ROLL. THIS IS SENATE
BILL TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR BY
SENATOR BATES THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER NO
WIENER NOW SENATOR BATES HI
BATES HI CABALLERO. CORTESE
MCGUIRE REQUIRE NO PHOTOBOOK
SKINNER ENTER NO I'M BURKE.
CASKEY ALL RIGHT THAT IS THREE
KNOW ABOUT ONE TO THREE ONE
THROUGH PUT THAT ON CALL FOR
SENATOR JOE DOE- FEDERAL CALCIUM
CENTER AMER NOT RETURNING OKAY-
WE HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
HERE SO- WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
AND OPEN THE ROLES ON- OR BILLS
AND A CENTER TO AGO VOTER ON
EVERYTHING OTHER THAN- THE LAST
BILL. OUR ISSUES BUT OKAY DO WE
KNOW IF SHE COME BACK. OKAY I
WAS JUST WALDRON THE ROLE FOR
THE CURRENT MEMBERS. YEAH I
THINK. RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT. OKAY-
WILL OPEN OPEN THE ROLE ON ITEM
ONE SB NINE FOURTEEN- PLEASE
COSTA MEMBERS. THIS IS SENATE
BILL NINE FOURTEEN BY SENATOR
RUBIO CURRENT VOTE IS SIX TWO
ZERO BOTH CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING I CENTER CORTES HE WROTE
ON. CLINTON CORTEZ'S FIVE
ACQUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE OCHO BOOKS
. OKAY WE'LL PUT THAT BACK ON
CALL I'M SORRY. OKAY NEXT ITEM
TO SB THIRTEEN OH SEVEN PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS THIS IS
BILL A SENATE BILL THIRTEEN OH
SEVEN BY SENATOR RUBIO CURRENT
VOTED SIX TO ZERO CHAIR ANDVICE
CHAIR BOTH VOTING HI SENATOR
CORTEZ IN. HIGH COURT AS THE AYE
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE OCHO BOOK.
AND THAT IS EIGHT ZERO CAPITA
BACK ON CALL WAITING THREE SB
TEN SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS. CURRENT LOTUS
FIVE TO ONE SHARE VOTING I
ADVISED HER VOTING NO SENATOR
CORTEZ HE NOT FULLY PARTISAN NOT
VOTING MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE OCHO
BOOK. AND THAT IS SEVEN TO ONE
WE'LL PUT THAT BACK ON CALL-
WILL NOW GO TO THE CONSENT
AGENDA PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS. CURRENT GOAL IS SIX TWO
ZERO CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING
I CORTESE. AYE CORTESE AYE
MCGUIRE. FIREFIGHTERS EIGHT ZERO
PUT THAT BACK ON CALL- ITEM FIVE
SP TEN NINETY FOUR PIECE CALLED
ABSENT MEMBERS. CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE TWO ZERO CHAIR VOTING I
ADVISED HER NOT VOTING- CORTESE
ALL RIGHT CORTEZ'S I REQUIRE.
WHERE HI A CHOKE. BATES NO. THAT
IS OF SEVEN TO ONE WE'LL PUT IT
BACK ON CALL- SB. ELEVEN NINETY
FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CURRENT VOTE
IS SIX TWO ZERO CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING RIGHTS AND OR
CORTES A- HI. WHAT DOES HE AYE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE I- TROUBLED
EIGHT ZERO WILL PUT ABOUT ON
CALL- WE- TO TEN ALREADY WILL
NOW GO TO- ITEM ELEVEN SB NINE
THIRTY. CURRENT ABSENT MEMBERS
CURRENT- IS SIX TWO ZERO CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING BY SENATOR
CORTEZ. CORTEZ THE AYE MCGUIRE.
WHERE CHAU BOOK EIGHT I WILL
PROVIDE ON CALL AND THEN FINALLY
ITEM TWELVE SB TWELVE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CURRENT VOTED SIX TO ZERO CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING I SENATOR
CORTEZ ALL RIGHT. THE I AM
REQUIRE. CHOIR HI EIGHT ZERO.
OKAY WE'LL PUT THAT BACK ON
CALL- SPINEL- CONSIDER TO AGO
WITH THE ONLY MISSING VOTE. OKAY
THANK YOU EVERYONE ELSE WILL
JUST OFF THE WEIGHT CENTER JOKES
RETURN.
THANK. OKAY WE WILL OPEN THE
ROLE- WE'LL START WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE- SB NINE FOURTEEN
PIECE CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS.
CURRENT VOTED SIX TO ZERO CHAIR
IN THE VICE CHAIR VOTING BY
SENATOR MITCHELL BOOK. A
TROUBLED BY TEXAS A NINE TO ZERO
FIVE BILLS OUT- NUMBER TWO S. B.
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN PLEASE HOLD
OUT SOME NUMBER CURRENT VOTE IS
EIGHT ZERO ULTRABOOK. NUMBER TWO
NUMBER TWO- HI. BUT TROUBLED HI
HATS NINE ZERO THE BILLS OUT
ITEM THREE SB TEN SIXTY SEVEN
POLICE CALLED AFTER MEMBER
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX TO ONE WITH
CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED HER
VOTING NO ACTUAL BOOK NO
TROUBLED NOW. THAT SIXTY TO
INCLUDE THE CONSENT OF THE BILLS
OUT THE CONSENT AGENDA PLEASE
CALL ABSENT MEMBER CURRENT GOAL
IS A TWO ZERO CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING I ACTUAL BOOK I
TROUBLED BY. NINETY ZERO CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT. I FIVE S. B.
TEN FOUR CALL YEAH A MEMBER.
CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN TO ONE
SHARE VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING
NO ULTRABOOK NO TROUBLED. THAT'S
SEVEN TO TWO. BILLS OUT. OUR
NEXT SB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CURRENT LOTUS EIGHT ZERO CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING BY A CHOKE
HI THE TROUBLED BY THAT'S NINE
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT- I REMEMBER
TEN SB TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CURRENT
VOTE IS ONE TO THREE WITH CHAIR
VOTING NO VICE CHAIR VOTING I
ACTUAL BOOKS I WOULD TROUBLED BY
THAT'S TWO TO THREE. OKAY SB
TWELVE EIGHTY FOUR VALVES AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED-
NUMBER ELEVEN SB NINE THIRTY.
KERN VOTED EIGHT TO ZERO FOR THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING I
PATROL BOAT. SORRY SEPTEMBER
ELEVEN CORRECT ELEVEN. I BUT
TROUBLED BY NINE ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT AND THEN FINALLY ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE S. B. TWELVE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE CALL THE OFFICE A MEMBER
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TO ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING
I OCHO BOOK I WOULD CHOKE I
THAT'S NINE ZERO. AND THAT. IS
OUT- SO I WERE TO THANK- TO. FOR
PROTEST IN THE SENATE HOUSING
COMMITTEE- AND- REALLY
APPRECIATE IT AND WITH THAT- WE
ARE ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU. I DEFINITELY ROCK YES
QUESTION CAN BE CURIOUS TO SEE
WHAT RESTAURANTS WERE LIKE THIS
MORNING. HEY WITHIN ONE MEDIA
LIKE SENATOR WE HAVE LIKE YOU
JUST ME TO THIS. ONE I LIKE.
WAIT TO. THE SAME TIME- I
GOODNESS AND YOU KNOW I'M THEY
WERE JUST BECAUSE WE'RE JUST
TALKING TO. IN JUNE WHEN WE HAVE
TO DO THE S. BILL AND THEIR
MEDIA PER THE STREET. SO THEY
SAID BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO BE
GOING BACK AND FORTH. ALL ABOUT
NINE. NINE HE WAS SACKED
PRODUCES THERE'S LIKE RECENT
THIS MORNING HAVE COMMITTEES AND
SAME TIME. I'M IN IT NUMBER
WHAT'S THE YEAR THE DISCUSS. AND
THAT THE FROM THE WITNESSES.
THAT TO ME VERY POOR LIKE I HAVE
A- BUT I I'VE YEAH LISTENED TO
MY STOP AT THE.